when i was 12 or something we were shown
big bird goes to japan and then
everybody came to me all the sudden and
they're like do you have a
kimono do you pay
in years or do you eat sushi every day
welcome back to the trash taste podcast
i'm your host and unfortunately i'm
hosting with a guest sometime
now we've completely messed up the order
now haven't we
i know it used to be that garm was
always there i saw that
yeah and none of them has aired yet but
like joey's hosted the blast you guess
yeah
so i'm sure like the subreddit is in
anarchy right now it's like
the verse has been destroyed
and that's my time to host with the
wonderful reina scully of course
the honor thank you so much for having
me hey yes
it has been a [ __ ] millennia since we
all caught up with you
it's been quite a while uh well over two
years
between us well over three years between
us and never
yeah i think i mentioned the first time
for you well i met you very very briefly
but you don't probably
remember no no no no no no no no
no at ax but you're cosplaying is like
chun li i think oh yeah that sounds
about right
you were like i was like oh hi because i
was with jerry and then that was the
first time i met you right
no that was um two years after no one
knows
we met in 2016. was it really yeah after
we met
um then we like randomly shot in japan
and i was like i need to go buy a bunch
of eroge and we were like yeah let's
make a video oh yeah
yeah we spent like six hours in that one
irrigate shop
i think i remember watching it
the whole time like for seven minutes
straight it's just like us talking in
mosaics and then like cutting really
well i mean it's like being on a zoom
call in public now with the filter
behind you it's like hi everyone here's
the video just everything is blurry
because i remember watching that video i
remember thinking it looks like you know
one of those undercover cop videos when
i'm like
like bust like like the pedophile or
something you just you just like
sneakily
like going around the shop and you're so
much of food
so before we jump right into the deep
end of content i think reyna you should
probably introduce yourself to the
audience who might not know who you are
yes um i don't really know what i do
anymore because
due to the pandemic i had to like really
kind of do different things that i
normally do but
i do do youtube i'm normally a host for
other channels like first we feast i
have a
show called gochi gang where oh wow
right i totally you've literally like
done everything i swear like that yeah
i always saw he's like a youtube jack of
all trades you were like always
you were like always everywhere always
hosting something
no i'm big i'm not
sorry i'm sure with emotions this is
also the first time i've like
collaborated physically with
another person in a whole year so like
even like physical contact
with another person is kind of intense
for me oh my god it's real
it's real and we're speaking english but
um but yeah normally
i'm a host and then i also do some voice
work i obviously do youtube but for now
it's really just to kind of keep myself
as relevant as possible until my hosting
gigs come back
right yeah because most of your hostings
are overseas yeah they're overseas
and also even like voicing stuff i
recently just uh
did a couple japanese voices for some
video game companies here but
i had to record myself alone in my home
and like
yeah like i had to use my own mixer and
i was so scared so
even like i don't even go to studios
anymore so again this is very exciting
i'm honored thank you well i mean like i
guess like
how i found you and i think how a lot of
people also know you is back in the day
you're on sauce fan yes okay yeah that
is definitely that's what i mean
literally reina has done everything like
rayna has been around forever dude
that's how i discovered it you're like
royalty
you know there's actually an ongoing
joke about 42.
i actually came on this podcast
specifically to destroy
the rumors yes that's what i came to
destroy people with facts and logic
and i have to throw you under the bus um
last time
yeah yeah yeah two years ago when we
were doing that yeah um
in one of the videos you loudly and
jokingly were like
no she's really 42 everybody and
everyone believed you
you had like the silliest look and you
were just like running around just like
yelling and yet they all believed you
they want they want the truth more you
know
it bothers me so much like as i get
older and as i
like approach that age and that like
curve gets closer
it'll be right eventually right you know
a broken clock is right two times a day
right
people watch that video next year and
being like well she's actually 42 now
i feel you're one of those like youtube
personalities where it's kind of like
everyone knows who you are but there
isn't like a specific moment in time
where
people came to know you it was you're
one of those personalities where it's
like
i mean if you're watching she's hosting
everything in my life
it's the kind of name of phase where
it's like yeah i've definitely seen you
somewhere
but i can't pinpoint one right i can't
place it i get that a lot yeah you've
been to you've been involved in so many
different projects and so many different
channels
as like the professional host that if
anyone's in like the nerd industry
especially the anime industry
they've definitely seen your face around
oh yeah yeah i worked really hard in the
beginning so to establish myself at
sourcefed they
obviously wanted they were you know
ramping up to gain other hosts
and i was their third generation host
and they definitely wanted to get into
anime and
before that i was translating anime for
fan subs and for crunchyroll so i was
like
i made sure i secured that professional
angle so that i
i have like something to talk about
exactly it's not just like oh like i
i promise i know what i'm talking about
it's like no i know the technical stuff
so i can kind of
delve into really strange things if i
need to or things
like people don't really reveal normally
so so so source said was like the first
big
thing yeah i would say so how did you
get involved with that yeah and i'm also
curious because i'm sure the view is
gonna be the same way
i know i've heard sourcefed i know that
all i know is that philip defranco was
jumping right into it back then with
that um i don't really
i i get sued by phil
i i don't know fully what sourcefed is
so maybe explain to the audience while
you're like what it is and how it became
a thing
sure so sourcefed was pretty i'd say
like
og youtube where they started with this
thing called 20 minutes or less and
they'd have these really quick
short segments where they would delve
into news but make it really comedic
because the original
og-3 were comedians and they were very
intellectual too so they knew how to
mold the story into a very digestible
but also like a funny way so they were
really good at selecting stories
yeah and they obviously purposefully did
not choose like intense or like
depressing things and
uh they really made a name for
themselves they left that's a depressing
[ __ ] to philly d right
at least like like he has a lot a little
bit of a long-form
platform where he's able to talk about
it so it's not like dismissing it
necessarily
so but yeah um and i think they were
part of the
original youtube startup program
where i think phil was given startup
money from youtube to start up
sourcefed and that's how he yeah and
that's how he kind of ragtag
handled that and hired the three this is
when the partnership program was just
like really early days right yeah and
very exclusive where people were just
like oh you can make money
from being a youtuber what is going on
this is like 2009 2010 maybe
yeah yeah because i was an intern in
2012 actually that's how
they found me i moved to la for fun and
also i was like sick of the snow in new
jersey that's where i grew up
and i auditioned for well i didn't
audition i
got hired as one of their interns and i
was like i was phil's intern as well
and he had me guest host
he had me guest host a sexy ladies
segment
i don't remember when people were well
ready for the thumbnails right yeah yeah
yeah
it's like that was the first time i was
ever on camera
[Music]
so anyway how did this pitch come about
he's like listen right i got a job that
only you can do
sexy i don't want to apply for this no i
was just his intern i was like getting
him lunches and coffee and i was like
and i was just doing some
uh like research for metadata kind of
thing was it was it a thing where
i don't want this to seem too
misogynistic could you like spice it up
a little bit maybe
that was actually exactly it okay okay
how exact that was
i know you phil yo yo ashley do you want
to host a new segment for us
and it literally like the segment was
called
intern reina brings in the sexy lady
can't make this [ __ ] up
[Music]
so that happened that's probably a past
that phil kind of wants to like brush
under the rug right
that is the most 2012 sounding title so
that's when phil started jumping right
into it
i had to say sup nation that's why i
like rings in my head
[Music]
but it was actually a lot of fun and um
darren
uh was the cameraman at the time he was
the producer and
he was so good and he was like so
professional and he
really i don't know he like brought me
into this new world of being
not an intern but talking on camera and
i was so nervous but
it was just like so much fun and also i
was talking about sexy ladies which i
was like
yeah i'll do that we could be talking
about worse things yeah
the worst part about it though was that
it was this new
fresh 18 girl who was being like
who was being i guess i googled before
that but she like just turned 18 so it's
like
it's legal now and i had to like do that
yeah so youtube ten years ago was a
different planet it's a difference yeah
and that was like monetized yeah i mean
i can only imagine
it makes me feel sad that when you refer
to sourcefed you're like oh it's an og
youtube channel and i'm just like oh
[ __ ] i guess it is isn't it
oh [ __ ] you're you're an og youtube
channel
because like i've been following phil
since like since like close to when he
started right
so i remember when he announced
sourceford i was like oh what's this
what's this new venture that he's doing
this sounds exciting and
now that it's like now an og dead
channel that is just buried in people's
memories like that
that makes me feel a bit sad i'm just
having this realization live on camera i
i used to watch sourcefed a lot
oh my god my [ __ ] like yeah i used to
watch it a lot
i was like at one point i would say it's
probably one of my favorite channels to
watch wow
just because it's like again it's like
you know it wasn't like as
you know i watched phillyd as well
obviously the new stuff but it was also
just like
you know it was edutainment yes right
yeah that's that was like the big
selling point
i was like you get to learn some [ __ ]
but at the same time you can have fun
with these comedians
yeah yeah and it kind of you kind of
remember it because it's funny i think
that was also the other point of it like
it's shareable because it's not
dark and it's also funny so it makes
sense to like put all over facebook kind
of thing everybody else
watching and be entertained by it so
yeah it was like a brilliant idea and
they started making other sub channels
like sourcefed nerd
and then i ran their gaming channel
super panic frenzy with steven septic
and that was like my golden time i'd say
like that was when i was already finally
comfortable being on camera it was right
right and then i left for crunchyroll
so so what made you leave
um i was really heartbroken that
they cancelled super panic frenzy
because on my gaming channel because
we were hitting all the numbers like
hard we were completely setting all the
goals and
um at the time we were owned by
discovery digital networks and yeah and
i remember that i i remember sorcered
ending and then they tried to continue
it
under a different name yeah something
right yeah that was bad that was um
i think it's like a completely different
company now but right
when sourcefed like when discovery let
go of sourcefed somebody tried to pick
it up and kind of like almost
zombie still using the reanimated and
usurping it
yeah like they took the same channel
renamed it and
hired different hosts to uh continue on
this show
as though yeah yeah it was it felt very
like puppeted and straight
it kind of felt like you went to a
friend's house and there was just a
stranger sitting there
pretending to be your friend who's my
house now wait a minute what
what's going on i'm at connor's house
welcome back
good to see you back here it was like oh
that's not connor that's a connor
animatronic
that's so worried oh my god yeah i i
didn't i didn't follow any of the sauce
food stuff at all i think
on youtube i was not watching that kind
of stuff then i think i was still
watching like gameplay stuff i was like
exclusively in like call of duty
walkthroughs or something stupid
yeah i think yeah that was fantastic um
we had
andre this independent animator uh
make animations of short clips from
things like our podcasts and our table
talks
and they were very good because he was
very good the animator did everything he
like really expanded the comedy
[Music]
i remember when that came yeah and i was
like [ __ ] i'm gonna be out of this
um yeah actually so anime club existed
before me and uh meg turney was doing it
and she kind of did it like
all these names sound so familiar but
quite like not quite i don't have
like a face to play now is like a
cosplayer
yeah and um she's like a sexy model yeah
and
yeah she's doing great um and we still
keep in touch i miss her a lot she
misses japan
um but yeah so she started it and
i do believe they wanted to expand it
and it would obviously make sense if
somebody who
who like has some kind of professional
experience with anime
as well on top of like being japanese
that's kind of a no-brainer there yeah
so i was legitimately hired mainly to do
that to fill that role um and it was
just when she
was on her way out so i was like i
basically replaced her
yeah and yeah and then will and i took
it over but
it was fun but it was really difficult
because
the style was supposed to be that i was
the so-called
expert kind of teaching the novice yeah
yeah he has all these questions but
they're
so very left field that like i didn't
know how to
kind of bring it back because because i
think um you know all
you know all respect to mctourney but
you know because i remember when she was
handling anime club
um which was like season one of anime
club it's like
it started a lot of let's say
controversial opinions within the anime
community because i
remember it was the first time where we
saw like this kind of mainstream
youtuber
try to like bring the anime culture to
the wider mainstream audience nowadays
it's like pretty you know
pretty soon every brand is like hey i
like anime everyone talks about talking
about now but like we at arby's love
adam we have this like anime show
that was like produced by you know
philly d or you know he had his name
involved with sourcefed and this was
like the most mainstream
anime had gotten to any youtuber and you
know all my love to make
um there was there was like some
some episodes where i said like some
lines were said well i can't remember it
was her or like her guest host
where where they called like i think
they called
formeta alchemist a shojo anime
i could just feel i could feel the the
like the unbridled grudge
in you as you're talking like you
remember how anime fans were back yeah
yeah
yeah they they they saw this medium as
like a [ __ ] holy ground
yeah um so i think it didn't help as
well that the show itself was like
probably the most
well produced out of like any attitude
content
at the time so it just felt like you
know like yes i do watch anime
younger generation yeah because i i felt
like it wasn't her fault it was just the
fault of just
i think the way the show was set up just
wasn't wasn't the right way to like
really embrace the medium of anime or
like introduce it to a new audience but
i'll say this like what you and william
did you
you made like it you you it was a huge
improvement right
because i i feel like i feel like the
chemistry was a lot better
but like what i wanted to ask is that uh
did you going into this did you know
about all the negative feedback that
you've gotten from like anime like anime
fans
um as a translator i was already pretty
connected to a lot of different anime
sites
so i was well aware well well aware
isn't the right way to say it i was
aware
but putting a face to the opinion is a
whole other world
and the backlash is quite scary however
exactly how you said i think people
were quite excited about the improvement
and there's very
there's a lot less you can criticize
like to a translator yeah so and also
i'm like actually japanese
so that like kind of mattered in their
eyes as well that's also like another
creepy thing about anime fans right like
especially back in the day there's like
so much more nerd cred if like you're
actually japanese that means you can
watch it without yeah
that mattered and i think that overrode
any major major criticisms and also
again
i was already in that sphere so i was
conscious of what to say what not to say
if will said something weird i'd go to
the producer and the editor and be like
you've got to cut that out
because because like i i've always been
curious because you know no disrespect
to meg
it felt like you did take a lot of the
criticisms that they had gotten and
really
use that to improve the show and i was
wondering if it was like a conscious
decision
very conscious okay okay um because
so it really was unfair to meg because
she was the only person in the entire
building that even knew anything about
it
so the editors didn't know so she had to
source all the photos herself yeah
i mean granted i did too after i took
over but there was no
producer that oversaw what was correct
or incorrect or knew the sub
audience or like knew how to like hunt
reddit for it and stuff like that
so i came in and i kind of started from
the backlog
and i was you know due to the research i
knew
everything that would make sense would
maybe hit would be bad
is wilkin understand like that was also
the other tether right like you have to
make sure that
the novice character is going to be
able to kind of follow it as well
without having to use it because i guess
he needs to like
channel people who are watching the
video that don't know anything about it
right right but again sometimes he was
so random that it was hard to be like
nobody's thinking that
don't ask them it sounds like before
they just it was the situation where
like the kid is like oh that uh the
teacher's like oh that one kid's good at
computers he can fix everything
right yeah that's exactly what get him
in
i feel like meg just got put in there
because she was anyone that knew
anything about anime at all and you know
it's awful because it was such a passion
project of hers and she
wanted to do it as a fan but you have to
get technical you have to yeah
especially if you don't have a producer
and an editor that's going to fix it on
your behalf after you're done like yeah
she wanted it to be opinionated and fun
and
what she likes and that would have
worked maybe now
but that was so not the case on a
platform like sourcefed so
yeah i don't know it's just like yeah it
just did not i feel like you were like
that idea was a few years
ahead of its time in terms in terms of a
talk show about anime that could really
do well on youtube now
i feel like back then it was just there
was no way it was really hard to get new
people into anime especially on youtube
and a lot of the backlash you got were
just from anime fans
right as being like okay no we don't
want we don't want this to be the
representation of what anime fans are
and now
now i just think man we were anime fans
were pretty [ __ ] toxic back then as
well
they still are they love you love you
guys but we are
i feel like early youtube they were like
next well yeah because i think at that
point again like it's like gone saying i
was like the holy grail was like this
protected thing where it was like it was
theirs
and it had been like tarnished i kind of
understand that though like when i was
younger and i was
in japanese school in new jersey
when pokemon came to the states i was
like that's ours
what are you doing his name is ash
you know what i mean like even as a kid
like i kind of understood that
exclusivity thing so i
also like as an anime fan i understood
anime fans and i actually
surprisingly didn't get as much hate
especially
throughout sourcefed they were actually
very happy that i existed
so yeah i was super lucky there got a
lot of hate and crunchyroll i think it
was just
because it was so obvious that you were
just a weeb through and through
yeah yeah yeah people just saw you and
they were just like okay she is one of
us yeah you weren't you weren't right
yeah you weren't trying to pretend to be
a weird you were a waiter yeah a lot of
the time with these
these you know company videos there's so
much of it is like
hi guys we love the thing that you love
right it's kind of wacky huh
this thing's wacky too oh you guys this
is so wet
my favorite show fml this was a cringe
moment right guys
it was like i wanted to give people the
benefit of the doubt back then and there
was like that
uh that thing that got uh that was in
one show and i think the other thing was
you were one of them was talking about
baccano yeah
and uh i think the guy who was new there
he said oh it's
kind of feels like a ripoff to fma right
because there's
there's uh barcano said on a train and
there's an episode of fma that said on
the train
and even even that was like the space
bar movement for me as well
and and i just think you did you did
such a good job because this is the
environment that
you that you came into to prove people
that okay there is an actual
big improvement to this show and you did
a great video still exist on youtube
sorry does that video still exist on
youtube i think he's got another anime
club he's
not on youtube anymore so like train to
bassan
it's a little bit of a rip-off of
hogwarts because they're both on a train
so unfortunately you're just gonna have
to take my words but anyone who watched
source fed back in the day in the anime
community knows that that was like
shared around
yeah yeah right so i'm trying to build
up the timeline in my head so you're in
source forever how long were you
i was there for damn uh let's see i was
an
intern first which was 2012. i was a
actual host in 2014. i was there for
two years but it no i was there for
three years but it felt like
much longer yeah well it sounds like a
really important part of like the career
absolutely
yeah and i also did a lot of things with
them afterwards so
kind of really did feel much longer yeah
yeah yeah and and so
the reason why you left is obviously
because it did just get wiped
uh well i left before that yeah so yeah
this is such a strange thing i never
talked about it before but
um my everything went into our gaming
channel
me and stephen septics and we were doing
so well and then they canceled it anyway
and i was so heartbroken and when they
say they
just said that there was no budget for
it which is such a i know it's a let's
play
like why like they buy the game on steam
yeah i know it's crazy we don't have ten
dollars for the steam game
but i must say septic did spend over two
grand on cs go cases once
uh using the company card and we wrote
it off and it was like okay
it's that's their fault they should have
just told us that that's hilarious
that is such an epic game of movies
yeah and he got like the [ __ ]
butterfly knife
whatever but anyway well yeah they said
there's no budget and there's like a lot
of like production reasons
behind it but um then because the
whole channel was dissolved and i was
a og like host for that turn for that
time
they brought me back into sourcefed nerd
and sourcefed proper
instead of like outright laying me off
but they laid off
septic and i was like so weird about
that but i also needed money to survive
in area so there was not much i could do
about it
and then when i left septic got hired
again
as a as like a or like a source fed
proper member i know i know so strange
yeah
and that's when i kind of realized
something was super super wrong with the
entirety of the company not that there's
anything wrong with steve but you know
the fact that
letting someone go and then bringing
them back in later
and then like it almost felt like they
were like trying to separate us so that
we wouldn't try something on our own
[Music]
but yeah that was like a major thing
also you know discovery like owned our
face and soul
for x amount of years according to our
contract because we were like oh god
yeah so that was also i'm suspecting
that was also why they
maybe wanted to keep us separate so that
our faces wouldn't be together on
another thing that we created
because you and steve i guess created
like a brand almost created like a brand
for your arm yeah yeah
yeah i ended up like kind of doing that
which was amazing but also i do think
that that probably was dangerous for the
company and for the shareholders maybe
but
because the thing about you know uh big
companies hiring youtubers to do videos
for the company
is that the audience end up being loyal
to the host and the personality because
they're
they're the heart and soul of the show
so even if they leave
you've already created a brand for
yourself right right and
yeah i mean it's it [ __ ] is pretty
scummy that you know yeah
yeah stuff like that has you know
happens it sucks like now having been in
the industry in many different ways like
as an independent youtuber as somebody
that's hired by bigger companies like
it's entertainment media um new media
old media it kind of can't
be helped right now i think it's
starting to improve or maybe change
in a way that's beneficial to
independent creators especially with
youtube and twitch and everything like
that but it's still very difficult like
the
biggest chunk of money that's solid is
definitely still
in the hands of bigger companies so yeah
that does definitely
kind of sway yeah what i wanted to know
is you've
you've obviously you got involved in
this by being an intern for
philly d is that the job that you wanted
like did you want to work in youtube
um i was a fan and i was just watching
him and i was
uh watching some of sourcefed and i
was what was i doing oh yeah i was an
apprentice pastry chef in new jersey
i know i know after you graduated is
that what you wanted to do though
um i this is so weird i knew i was good
at it
sounds so pretentious i don't want it to
be but i knew i was good at
it i mean you became an apprentice all
right so i guess it makes sense
just own it right now i was [ __ ]
amazing i was like really good at it
i was making wedding cakes and i
actually made uh japan airlines first
class desserts for a year damn yeah that
was me
yeah she was pretty [ __ ] good at it
yeah
so i was doing that and but i didn't
like it because you have to go to work
at
one no two a.m right and then you're out
at like
like 12 1 p.m but it's i don't know like
i
i got kind of depressed i think not like
actually depressed but i was not well
that doesn't really leave you much time
to do anything
you obviously need to sleep right so you
try to sleep during the day but that's
i don't know like i never want to do
stuff yeah i was younger i was like i
want to like party and play and do all
these things so
i don't think it was just it made a lot
of sense for me at the time and
uh then my now husband but then
roommate slash boyfriend and i were like
we like let's just do something crazy
and we moved to la
and i just had we actually auditioned
together
i got it he did it this episode
is sponsored by ritual we deserve to
know what we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every day
rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients in bioavailable forms
your body can actually use
gentlemen let me tell you what you won't
find in ritual sugars no
gmos major allergens synthetic fillers
and artificial colorants can you believe
it
plus the fresh taste and delay release
capsule design makes taking your
vitamins
easy holy [ __ ] why am i not taking these
now already ritual is made traceable
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind
visible supply chain i love when i know
the things that i put into my mouth
so get those key nutrients today without
the bs ritual is offering our listeners
ten percent off during your first three
months visit ritual.com to start
your ritual today
so you auditioned with your husband yeah
and um
i got it and it kind of mesmerized me as
a fan
being able to be on the opposite side of
it and being the intern that like
researches stuff
and i do believe that there was a lot of
like political stuff going on at the
time so i was also
re-educated which was really interesting
for me having having been out of
college already i was like oh this is so
much fun there's so much to learn and
then phil wanted
me to me to be on camera and i was like
no way
like you want me to bring in these sexy
girls
i thought you never off yeah i was here
to do that
that was my plan wow
yeah so i i really started as a fan for
lack of a better term i wasn't like an
obsessive fan but there wasn't
i mean i don't think he would have hired
you if you were an obsessive yeah he
would have like smelled it right away
he so what came after sauce said then
after sourcefed i went straight to
crunchyroll are you just giving an offer
or
yeah i was getting an offer and um i was
actually given an offer while i was at
sourcefed and
i was like oh no i didn't hear that like
nothing happened um but then after i
left we had like a clean
break with sourcefed they knew i was so
distraught over the gaming channel
no no like please we don't want you to
like go postal so just like
um so i went to crunchyroll and it was
actually
a lot of fun but i ended up
shouldering a lot of the production i
thought it was going to be more like
sourcefed where
there's a crew and i would have some
production say but they hired me as
talent
slash producer so i guess i should have
been expecting more of that
responsibility but
it was it was really ragtag and
um and like you know what you were
saying before about the
anime community crunchyroll has a very
aggressive anime community um
both oh we know don't worry it's a good
thing and a bad thing because some
people
are fans of the company that just want
the company to do well but then there
are people that are like criticizing it
which makes sense too that companies
should do better right like there's a
lot of kind of factors to it where you
can't really get mad at the whole
situation
yeah and it was hard answering all of
that right like it was hard
i i feel like you got an impossible job
you know thank you
sleevely that means so much time one
more time so i can like lock it up
one more time you had an impossible job
thank you
the words that she wants to hear the
game
five words that make you do this i mean
you know you were just like a martyr for
crunchyroll
honestly like well you know every time i
saw crunchyroll videos you know
i think because everyone just has that
air of skepticism towards control
unfortunately
you know and you know we've worked with
country role you know and i think we've
also been skeptical of crunchyroll but
yeah i think the viewers especially
love dogging on crunchyroll i mean i
mean controversial they're the boogeyman
yeah concho could have had like [ __ ]
jesus christ you know reeves
or keanu reeves say the same thing right
and people would find problems with them
you know
i feel i feel crunchyroll fans like oh
not crunchy fans but crunch all haters
quote unquote
to like kind of get a little too over
obsessive with criticizing crunch roll
to the point where it's like
okay i get it like yes it's not a
perfect company they have a lot of stuff
to work on
but give them a [ __ ] break oh that
means a lot like jesus christ like
and and especially like again it's like
you had that impossible job of like
because all i feel all of the arrows
were like
pointed towards you right because you
were literally the face now they have a
face
yeah now they have a face and person to
point out right and i just felt
really [ __ ] bad that you were at that
point
yeah i remember actually i very very
specifically and vividly remember
uh one of your messages where you're
like hey are you and he was like so
uh you were being so careful with me
you're like are you okay like
i saw the last video like it's not your
fault i was like
oh um you know what i'm not reading the
comments anymore
yeah yeah yeah i'm like i think i'm okay
i was just like a warning call to be
like
don't read the comments yeah yeah
[ __ ] hell
and it was so weird because um i don't
want to mention specifically a video but
they weren't even mad at me it wasn't me
that they were mad at they were just mad
at something else that was happening
which was ad related
and they pushed it onto the video and
then they kind of like turned into its
own monsters
it was a sticky situation yeah and i'm
like that's the weird thing they're not
even mad at me
like i can't really i didn't know how to
feel about it right like if they're not
hating on me but i'm also the face so
they're like
[ __ ] you and you're facing these ads i'm
like that's not my bad like
it's the weirdest kind of hate to get as
a content creator i feel
like it's like it's not your fault but
[ __ ] you yeah they're like i'm so sick
of seeing your face every five seconds
like while i'm watching
attack on titan i was like i'm not even
sorry
so yeah that was that was interesting
but again because they weren't really
necessarily
angry at me as a person again i had that
like veil of protection where
i'm like like it's it's okay i hate
my company that i work for and represent
with my face
but yeah yeah i mean
another question i want to ask you as
well is like you've obviously done a lot
of hosting and everything like that
it seems like you just kind of got
thrown into it
you know starting with phil and sauce
fed did you ever go through any training
or was it just something you learned
on the job how to present i must say
the internship taught me everything
um as an intern you did
so much just like just like ashley is
back there
so like i see him taking notes like you
know there's so much
you're doing good ashley you're doing
good fantastic
he's just he's just doing his universe
never mind but you know you had to do so
much especially back in the day like i
learned
i learned cameras i learned audio
editing i learned research metadata
everything
um i learned how to backwards engineer
like some of the algorithm because it
was much simpler back in the day
yeah and then i actually worked for an
advertising
gaming company for a little bit where
they put me on
camera because they just needed somebody
and i
just happened to be a fast reader and i
was good at reading the prompter
so that's where i kind of got my
practice so to speak but
the bread and butter of my technical
knowledge definitely
came from the internship and then i got
to practice
being like a face and like talking on
camera and doing
pauses or reading really fast or making
sure the video cuts at two minutes kind
of thing and then
uh sourcefed came about and i just like
knew what i was doing so yeah yeah god i
wish i was as
like natural as you i was like being a
youtuber for
13 years now i still get a camera
pointed in front of me and if i don't
have you guys next to me i'm just like
uh uh hi guys
smash the like button i'm just so
miserably [ __ ] british so like any
time i have to like fake being happy
everyone knows i'm not like that like
like when i'm i'm like yo guys
everyone's like connors why are you
faking it
hi guys about this great show and
everyone's just like why is god talking
yet trick is drinking
like three red bulls beforehand that
doesn't sound sustainable
you sweat through all your clothes but
it works like you can
you can mimic that it's the reyna scully
method yeah three red bullets
just destroy your heart yeah that's how
you feel you'll look good on camera
just like hide those armpits and you're
good that's the same thing as just
saying like
you know what i do do a line of coke
right before i start
there are some people though that when
they smile you're like nice and then
there's people like me where it's like
whoa
i feel like you when you smile on camera
it looks like like a real person smiling
really
what do you mean you know what i mean
like you just see someone you're like
you're like that looks like a real smile
and other people you know when god
smiles too much i'm like what the [ __ ]
but i feel like the same for me or
people see me smile like what's going on
there is a trick about like smiling with
your eyes or you like kind of want to
squint like this
it's the these eyes yeah that's why like
you do that and then you put up
yes
you look like someone's holding you at
gunpoint i am i am small [ __ ]
hi guys welcome to trash taste connor
here
is it genuine if you if you just cut out
like this half
it just looks like you're done murder
this is why i get it
i hate it on a live stream every i wish
i was a youtuber sometimes max because
then people people don't ask you
you look tired i always look [ __ ]
tired you look you look
real you look angry connor like yeah
that's i'm british i'm always angry i
just my face is naturally angry it's too
fair though like you know so many of
like your fans and even you yourself
were like i have a really
serious resting [ __ ] i do i do it look
i i never noticed it up until you
pointed out
i do that now like yeah now i look at it
i'm like it's yeah
maybe what do you think i mean i don't
really think so but that's because you
know i watch your streams a lot
a lot yeah i'm really creepy you never
told me you literally just
walked into shoes like i've watched your
live streams and i'm like how many
a lot what that's so embarrassing
just say just say something oh my god
yeah why don't you tell me how you bring
in here first of all your chat's bananas
right so like i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna jump into that but
um
i don't know i mean i you know what i
was discouraged
why am i always like no i watch i watch
all your streams by the way
uh because i'm creepy like that but no i
watch i watch yours
uh quite often but when you jumped on
for like the first time in like maybe
two months or something
and i was like actually
and then i said something else like um
like not
not not like i want to play smash
brother or something i said something
gaming related
and then you answered that too and you
didn't
no because it's because like especially
recently i've had people because
every time because i kind of advertise
my streams as like i can also speak
japanese yeah yeah right so it's like
i get everyone's helping you know every
now and then no no every now and then i
get like
maybe like five per stream maybe like
five to ten like full-on japanese people
typing in my chat and i always reply
back in japanese
i thought you were just one of those
people you know what i'm not even wait
is your screen name not rayna scully
it's reina scully
i didn't read it i think funny is like i
know that
about you about like you say like you
know live from tokyo and it's like
japanese and english right so i was like
oh i bet he wants to talk japanese yeah
of course i do purposefully
wrote in japanese yeah you answered me
for like five
minutes and you didn't realize it was me
and then you answered me again
i think i was like really i forgot what
i was playing but i was probably like
really intensely into the game so i was
playing a game
i must have been tired you weren't tired
i must have said that you literally said
reign of scholars
complaining about something in one of
the streams and it was so funny
it was like complaint i complained about
a lot of things that's just me
i don't i forgot what it was
specifically but i i don't know it was
really funny how do you make the camera
zoom in like that when i can teach you
that
it's called a stream deck like yeah i
could be so
i've only ever streamed on behalf of a
company so i had like
people taking care of well you were
telling me the other day that you want
to get into twitch right
i really do it's super easy i mean you
you could do it
easily you you seem like your
personality that was like made for
twitch i'll be honest oh my god i really
want to but again i've only ever
streamed
for other companies or other people so
i've never had to like
do all the technical stuff myself and
i'm really afraid because
once at sourcefed we left the stream on
and we didn't do anything but
it was just on for like hours
hours like overnight like lights went
dark and the camera was still on
oh my god they've already thought of
some like meta arg or something like oh
my god they're telling us something
you know that would've been so cool but
no we're not that clever we're just dumb
enough to leave the camera on
and and like the whole thing was on like
streamed fully
and stuff and then when our one of our
editors went home he was like
like what the [ __ ] and then you like
went back and turned it all off yeah
it's
it's pretty hard to do that honestly
especially from your home right yeah
because i mean like it's literally
because like it's your pc you know it
i'm when i'm done streaming i'm probably
going to still be at the pc so i'm
probably going to like look at it
you know so it's really it's really no
you're i know it's like we'll get we'll
help you we'll harvey we'll be fine yeah
oh my god my heart i also i also
realized that like on twitch
it's so much more fun to watch people
that are streaming with other people
co-streaming and playing a game together
and stuff and i'm like i want no not
always that's not true
i feel like i feel like friends
it kind of goes both ways because it's
like sometimes there are some
people who watch twitch streamers
because they want to interact with the
actual person right yeah
but if you're if your favorite stream
was playing with another streamer
or playing with another person most of
the time they're not paying attention to
the chat
as often right as if they're on their
own right so they're like well what the
[ __ ] like i came all this way i'm
hanging out in the chat
i want your attention acknowledgement
yeah i want your acknowledgement yeah
it's like
i think like once you do it like you
stream enough your chat will understand
if you're playing with someone that they
you'll probably not be paying attention
to the channel yeah and you're like
yeah it's like 50 50 for me i read if
i'm playing alone i read the chat if i'm
not
if i play with someone else i kind of
ignore the chat yeah yeah yeah i watched
your stream with i think it was
iron mouse oh yeah yeah oh yeah i love
that one that was so much fun
is crazy she's great well is there like
anything you'd like
want to do if you start doing twitch
like do you want to play games do you
want to just do like just chatting
you know i i miss playing games i miss
playing
games like for the purpose of being on
camera so i do i
probably 50 50. streams coming soon
oh my god thank you um yeah i
i think i just want a different platform
than youtube right now
that's really what it is i'm a little
bit sick of making youtube videos
um we all feel it don't be like oh no
how my morning goes you know some days
i'm like [ __ ] i don't want to do this so
there's a like
it also depends on the youtube idea some
some of them are literally just like
okay here's the grind i'm gonna just
grind it out
some projects you're excited for but it
very much depends
yeah i think it really is just like a
pandemic world thing um i used to
make a lot of videos going out and going
to tokyo yeah joey like doing a bunch of
things and with like my friends in tokyo
and i don't like i think streaming from
or not streaming i don't like shooting
from my house because hey
i don't want to accidentally like reveal
where i am
exactly like i'm in the you know i'm in
the countryside so
it's a little bit hard to figure out
where i am but like just in case it's a
little bit freaky
and you know you're like i guess like
your inspiration is kind of limited when
you're just doing it from home by
yourself yeah someone got very close to
finding my
where i live right now oh how did i tell
you this no so like there was like
a bar code that was like roughly like
shown for like a second in one of my
videos from one of the packages i opened
right
right and uh they went around like
texting people being like i know where
connor lives
and then so and then what happened was
that even though this this barcode was
barely visible
somehow like you barely it's in the
background and somehow it's scanned
when you put the like when you put the
scanner to it that's what you meant i
didn't understand yeah yeah
so so like when you because when you get
a japanese package there's i think any
package there's always a barcode on it
yeah
and this was like in the background of
the shot and someone somehow scanned it
i have no idea how they got it like
the fidelity high enough yeah i have no
idea i was thinking
because they literally did the
enhancement because i i found
where it was and i was like there it
didn't even work when i was doing it
so i don't understand how they managed
to pull it off because then they were
going around sending me a screenshot you
know like i know
you live connor and then uh so i looked
at the thing and luckily japan post only
told my postcode which is still not good
but i was like all right
it's only a postcode i'm like yeah so i
was like close though
yeah i was like all right what are you
gonna do come to this giant ass place
with all these like
ten story apartments yeah i'm like what
are you gonna do
find my apartment i'm like i would i
would gamble even if you found a
building i lived in i'm like i'd still
feel
safe honestly yeah i'm like try and find
the door don't try and find the doors
but like i mean you know i was it was
very concerning just to be careful with
barcodes yeah yeah
i had no idea that was a thing so [ __ ]
that person going around
being like this is so cool i have
connor's address
but it's whatever i mean i was like all
right cool you're a loser
why would you see a barcode in the video
think i'm gonna scan that i'm gonna
[ __ ] try and scan that i love you
that's why i love him so much i must
find out where he lives
i mustn't toxin that's how much i love
him yeah i probably have cockroaches in
my apartment why would you want to find
out where i live i don't know
because he loves you and your cochrane
everything about you
all of you that's so [ __ ] creepy
yeah it was but yeah but i mean where
you live though it's
probably really safe though it is except
we just had a stabbing
first one in a hundred years or it never
happens
it freaked everybody out was this was
this like national news
um it was definitely like um
it was like she's all yeah she's like
professional oh [ __ ] i thought that's
awesome
yeah and um and it makes no sense but
then a whole week later
he didn't get caught and everybody
forgot so there's that
wow okay but um but that's a misnomer
that's not a good representation of
my like hometown it's very lovely and
quaint and wonderful feels
where i grew up there and when someone
died when i was like 18 they're like yes
the first death in this area in like 25
years
like murder jesus it's a big deal when
it normally doesn't happen
yeah in like tiny towns yeah that's the
thing with like especially like japan
right it's like there's either no crime
or like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like world war three yeah
yes
that's it's definitely there's no like
medium anymore yeah but i'm also
you know i lived in l.a for like eight
years where there was a shot
everywhere oh my god like i remember the
first like someone got stabbed
this never happened in l.a i remember
the first time
i went to la it was the first anime expo
i went to
and uh i remember like first morning i
woke up in the hotel right and it's one
of those like
radio clocks so like the alarm goes off
right and then the radio starts playing
right being like you know it's
the alarm yeah as the alarm right and i
was and i thought that was really cool
because like i've only ever seen that in
movies oh my
so cause like you know i was like okay
you know what like this is a feature i'm
just gonna go for this one morning and
see if it's like
you know cool or anything like you know
because i don't know i never had
anything like that in australia right or
japan
so i was like this this might be cool so
like alarm goes off at like 8 a.m or
something radio starts up or doesn't say
it's a beautiful morning here in los
angeles
last night we had three shootings
happening down in the downtown area
but it's a lovely summer day today have
a good one everyone i was like
all right i don't want to go outside
right now
mind the helicopters finding the
suspects yeah exactly
yeah that happened that's a real thing
yeah there's always a helicopter
shining like spotlights down everywhere
at all times yeah
just trying to go to like 7-eleven your
own personal spotlight
you don't do that where it all happens
what if i want a big gulp jeez
it'll be the last thing you ever drink
it's sloppy those days
[Music]
and nobody goes to class on friday so
sorry going back to the whole career
thing uh what happened after crunchyroll
i'm curious
um after is that where you started your
own youtube channel
actually i was kind of doing stuff on
sourcefed because
i felt like it was such a waste to not
be doing something on my own
and in my head i was like eventually if
i leave like i'll have something to fall
back on
i think everyone at sourcefed already
have like their own main channels
yeah yeah they did we were encouraged to
do it um to kind of like
also solidify your brand as a
on-camera home so they were helping you
build up a like
a way to leave them um well i don't
think they realized it because we
actually had to sign over our channel in
the beginning
or your personal channels yeah we had to
sign it
just for like a normal paying job like a
wage did you get any like buyout for fee
for that or anything
oh nice dark i know but um
i wasn't i don't think i was a
monetizable partner
channel until until like six months into
sourcefed and then
i started caring that like they were
taking i signed it off
[ __ ] my money um but also monetization
was different back in the day
there were no mid rules right like so
there was only like a pre-roll and
barely but also the money was way more
the out of the scene
was way more massive so i was not happy
but um but because
like you know i i can't do what i did
on super panic frenzy on my own i
wouldn't be able to hire septic like
that wouldn't be able to happen
i didn't have editors so like i knew
kind of what the trade-off was and i was
happy to be doing so also the security
and being
you know a hired host is much better so
i didn't mind especially because
i wouldn't be able to start my channel i
think from nothing without source fed
very aware of that so you could i think
no
no one no one thinks they can right like
it's until you just
make something like oh should people
want to watch yeah there's literally all
three of them yeah like
i think that's like phenomenal i would
not i do not think i would have been
able to i i don't
did any of you think i'm gonna i'm gonna
i remember like when i uploaded my first
youtube video
well after one day he got five views and
i was [ __ ]
you only refreshed it twice right
yeah that is literally the back in the
day where you had to be like you did
account your own refreshing
into the view count like you like
there's a hundred views but i've
definitely killed this at least 20 times
and i showed this to 20 friends and my
mom five times
that means there's 55 people out there
who thought i was listening isn't that
such a wholesome concern where you have
to like
worry about your own views of how much
you refreshed them yeah and back when i
used to like all my own videos because i
was like
i need to up the likage man like it's
not enough dude i'll admit i still like
my own video
do you i don't know because it's like
dude i [ __ ] love this video i made it
of course i like this video [ __ ]
obama memes just like
i literally get it every time i'm like
damn joey that's a [ __ ] good video
he uploads a video who's that guy
who's that guy he's just got a champagne
shelf just for himself and
every every video is like hacky
i'm the completely opposite right
because i don't like my own videos but
because alan edits my videos right so
sometimes there's a joke where he has to
screenshot my own video and he always
likes it i sometimes get comments being
like
oh why did gigguk likes his own [ __ ]
videos
i mean of course you do because you're
proud of the video you should be proud
of the video exactly
you feel like it's not my place to like
yeah i just like you're you're your own
account you have the ability
to like why is it i don't either i only
like ones
i'm sorry i've only liked ones where i
collab with people right like so like if
joey and i do a video i'll like that for
well so let's say you want a joke jerry
look at all these likes this is crazy
this is one more than normal
yeah oh my god yeah so sorry you were
saying about how you did
you do your own channel uh oh yeah okay
so i've been
doing it and then they gave it back to
me because i think they were afraid for
me or of me maybe when i left
i mean rightly so you know companies
aren't normally known for
going back on contract and kind of
owning
owning individuals you know that's
that's kind of scary actually
um we had a new like executive head
person that undid all of that even
before i left because it was like that's
[ __ ] up like no these people like
they would be fine yeah so he undid that
and i left
it was just worked out perfectly the
timing was good um
and then i left i did crunchyroll and
that was when my
own personal channel was doing quite
well probably because they wanted to
hear me talk [ __ ] about sourcefed
but also like i had like some nice
people watching and they were like
migrated over to my channel which was
really nice
and then you know i announced that i was
going to crunchyroll so they're like oh
like it's going to be even more
anime-centric or like we get to now
hear her talk [ __ ] about crunchyroll i
guess um
so that's kind of brainy why i left
crunchy
i mean i wanted to do honestly
i didn't know you could dude i've seen
those videos where it's why i left this
company and the video's like
yeah i was just kind of done uh they're
a nice company they're great guys but
yeah i was done and then it's like a
million views
yeah yeah yeah should have done that i
mean yeah i should have there was a
country rule was a little bit of a
different breakup
um it wasn't like aggressive or anything
like that it's just
um i still wanted to work adjacent
around them and also
because they're so deeply embedded in
the japanese anime community
and i went to like every industry
mixer thing that happened in japan which
was really scary
still i mean back in the day was way
scarier but um
i they like knew me as a japanese person
and i did like voice acting too already
so i didn't want to damage anything and
i was afraid
that even if it wasn't anything negative
if i did kind of like a
why i left crunchyroll thing then maybe
companies would distrust me a little bit
because you're openly talking about your
experience yeah and you know japanese
like totally frown upon that so i was
like let me not talk about that at all
ever again
yeah clean break but then i was doing a
lot of things with rooster teeth and uh
what haven't you done right at this
point just just name the stop naming
companies you haven't worked for in the
tournament in the nerd world i did
corner of the good day yeah you did i do
gaming anime and then i'm just like i
don't know i'm asian
like
but yeah i feel like i cornered those
markets really yeah that's my advantage
um
and yeah so i was doing a lot of hosting
and also like you know we had the
podcast the boys only club podcast and
stuff and that was really doing well
uh steve was doing really well with
sugarpine seven so i kind of was like oh
we could totally do this independently
like we don't need a company
ever again um but yeah and then i
moved to japan because i was like i'm so
sick of l.a
like i'm just too like truly sick of l.a
yeah la is hard hello yeah la seems very
intense it is now that i've been out of
it and maybe i'm kind of like
poisoned exposed facto from like maybe
kovid but i do miss la i miss visiting i
missed
the hustle i it really is neverland like
i genuinely feel like i did not age when
i was in l.a and
regardless of being there for eight
years it felt like i just got there all
the time
and i don't know it was like it is fun
if you can hit a sweet spot which i did
at one point but once you lose that
sweet spot in la
it's hard it's expensive things are
really stressful
yeah it definitely feels weird just
going to la and then just like kind of
dipping your toes in that industry just
like two weeks then being like
whoa okay yeah okay going to l.a and
doing anything like industry related
there i i feel like
man i i feel like i've done a month's
work yeah
networking and meeting people yeah ex
feels like a month jesus christ
is sponsored by boku an authentic
japanese snack box subscription that
sends you small delicacies from japan
saucy sweet savory damn all that umami
boxy has a variety of different types of
japanese snacks for you to try
every single month i didn't write this
melon wrote this
not only do you get some damn good
delicious treats they include fragrant
tea packets for you to brew and pair
with the snacks
so you at home snacking on those toxic
artificial food colored
american chips put that down now and get
yourself a boxy disclaimer this was
written by an american
i mean look what's inside tell us joey
what do we have in our box this month
all right look we have jagger choco this
is the thing that you
oh my god this is what gave me the
existential crisis
god okay i need to decide now there's
also there's also
as well which is a snack that i grew up
these are good those are pretty good
these are good too actually
hey this isn't an asmr podcast put that
down
gaunt box who even partners with
japanese artisan makers to make sure
you're getting
authentic flavors that's cross-cultural
food pollination
that's in the script anyways the folks
over at box who have hooked trash taste
views up within an
awesome deal use our link in code trash
taste 10 in the description to get 10
off your own boxy today you can save up
to 47
and don't forget the repeat customers
will get a themed box every month
so what are you waiting for start
snacking different today
back to the video so how long have you
been in japan now you moved
this will be my third year only three
yeah i know it feels like longer it
feels like you were here before i moved
no that's
did you ever live in japan before um i'm
i was here until i was born here and
then i was here until i was three
and then i would come back every summer
and winter um and i'd go to japanese
school
during that time i never had summers off
it's really sweet
wait so you had a holiday where you'd go
on holiday and go to school on holiday
yes it was it's messed up that's japan
yeah that is japan literally son you're
gonna love this i've booked you
for another six weeks of school you're
gonna love it yeah so in the end i would
get like maybe two weeks of summer
vacation
but like winter there's no school so
when you were watching like phineas and
ferb right and like
talking about all these days of vacation
that's a [ __ ] lie
it was heartbreaking because like i'd
watch all these other cartoons that were
like oh summer vacation
three months and i'm like what is that
god what is that i was like who has time
to camp when i have to finish my math
homework i was like wait i have this
kanji test like i have four conju tests
coming up
like what what's a break so how long did
you do that for until what age
until middle school um until end of
middle school so i graduated middle
school and then
14 13 13 yeah and then when
it came when high school came around um
my
parents and i got together and they were
like do you want to go for a japanese
university or an american university
like where do you want to like end up
and at the time i was like america
like there's this boy i have a crush on
like
so also like i only knew of japan during
the summer and winter so i was very
conscious that like i don't know how to
live in japan
yeah well yeah because you experienced
the two extremes right yeah and i was
like this isn't fun
like well it was it was but um i was
very aware that i
i don't know how to live in japan so and
also my english was
way more superior than my japanese even
after all that schooling
maybe i'm just dumb but uh yeah so i
decided i wanted to go to an american
university so
that allowed me to drop all of my
japanese stuff because you know
in america like you study for the sats
so so yeah that's what happened and then
20
years later i moved back to japan
wow full circle yeah um i never
ever in my life thought i would want to
be living in japan was that how you
imagined it to be
hmm well you know it sucks because the
first year i moved to so i moved like
towards the end of 2018
2018 into 20 end of 2019 was phenomenal
it's exactly how i envisioned it
work was flowing in the way i needed it
to and the way it made sense
i was going back and forth between the
us and japan like doing hosting gigs
here
here and there so the whole everything
like kind of tied together in harmony
and then you know i keep bringing it up
like i can't help it covet hit yeah
and now everything is so dislodged and
again like i said before i'm just trying
to stay relevant so that i can
have that back i can have that rhythm
and harmony back
and so now it feels more like a trying
to stay relevant catch up
game and it's just it's a little bit
weird but i'm sure it's weird for
everybody like it was a mess it's been a
message
i feel like i've only had a collective
like experience of moving here for about
like four months
because yes that's the the amount of
time i've stayed here before covered
here so
i don't really feel like my journey in
japan has like started i feel really bad
for you guys honestly because it's like
yeah again as you said like you guys
have been for almost two years now
mm-hmm
but it just feels like i feel like
you've barely gotten to experience
what it's like right i think i think i'm
very lucky that i ended up in the one
country where it
wasn't affected too heavily obviously
obviously you know it was kind of bad
here but you know we were able to keep
doing this podcast we wanted to like go
outside like it was like you know
whereas in the uk it was like
no one is allowed to leave your house
yeah at all and they were really strict
about it
right so i was like pretty glad i feel
like i kind of escaped but then also on
the other hand it's like i feel
super isolated here yeah like yeah you
know it doesn't help with the time zones
it's completely different so you better
get to talk to people on other time
zones you know so it's kind of uh
i think this is the first ever time i've
ever like felt homesick and i don't
normally feel like
home homesick but it was just more like
man just
you know not being able to see my family
and my friends that's
that's different from like you know
knowing that i can see them whenever i
like
i mean i i feel that and you know this
is technically my home like
yeah like i haven't been able to see my
family here for like over a year now
really yeah just because we well just
because like we agreed as a family
totally not see each other until covert
was over because like
last thing i want to do is give my
cousin coven of course
that would be [ __ ] so i'm curious was
there any like big reason or is like a
turning point that made you think like
we're moving to japan
um well the timing factor is that i was
just
really sick of la but also um
during the year that i decided to move
here i was going
back and forth to japan a lot and it
made me
miss every time i came back my wanting
to leave
miss japan yeah it would just get like
deeper and and intense and then
um you know i never grew up with my
family
at all it was always like my parents are
divorced and my mom raised me alone
in a foreign country it seems weird
saying america is my foreign country but
it is
and like i was never a citizen i was an
immigrant i'm a green card holder in
america i'm a japanese oh really
oh wow yeah i'm like a hard japanese
nationals
okay until i married my american husband
i was never actually an asian american
so all right
in a way i was like i don't know if i
belong here like i know i
i fake it and maybe that's like just
kind of like works its way into my
actual personality but
i'm like i like my japanese soul wants
to be with my family and
um my cousin had her first baby
and i was watching her grow up from la
and it like kind of broke my heart
because i'm like
the new generation has started right and
i can't even be there for that like i
missed the previous generation and like
you know like my second cousins are my
one of them just graduated
college and i didn't get to watch her
grow up when i used to babysit her when
she was a baby and
in the summers right in between kanji
tests and um
and i don't know like as i aged i really
felt like
i would be so angry at myself if i
didn't take this
opportunity right now to at least
experience living in japan
as a japanese person and being around my
family and then
um it actually did like the timing was
insane because
kova did happen but then unfortunately
my grandfather was like diagnosed with
cancer but i was there for him
and that's all i wanted like it would
have killed me it would have killed me
if i couldn't be here for them you know
yeah and in a way like first of all like
he was old as [ __ ] like it's okay like
he lived
last night and he smoked like a pack of
cigarettes it's fine
but like the fact that i got to
be there and i don't have to feel like
there was this big hole
that i you know in my life again because
i lost my grandparents on my dad's side
when i was younger and i was in college
and i
couldn't get out of college i couldn't
take time off to go see them so
that was like always such a huge stain
in my life and
yeah i was like this makes so much sense
so
i i feel really bad now because i
remember like as a kid
right you'd go to your you'd go to some
family reunion
and your parents well my parents would
introduce me to like this uncle or
something
and they'd be like oh i remember when
you were just a little baby i held you i
helped raise you up and
i was just like who are you thanos i
don't even know who you are
now like now that i've had like cousins
who you know have had kids and i've you
know
held them and seen them grow up as well
i know i'm going to say exactly the same
thing
i don't know i'm going to be that uncle
now and i know the kid is just going to
look at me the same way
you must have so much street cred with
them though because like my like
cousins and nephews they all want to be
youtubers
yeah and they're
i'm really scared because like my my
second cousin here
he just turned like six or seven yeah so
like he's about to like you know he's in
[ __ ] elementary school it's great
i love it it's like all elementary
school kids here in japan want to be
youtubers
so i am dreading the day where he
figures out that i'm a youtuber
no it's great because he hasn't figured
you're gonna be the cool uncle yeah dude
they they love
they're like they're like i've never met
you before who are you and i'm like oh
he's a youtuber by the way like
who is he playing which part of the
family is he from again sorry did you
play fortnite as well by the way
that's great yeah it's really funny i
don't know they're just immediately like
hello i'm paying attention
unfortunately my uh my a lot of my
nieces and nephews didn't take after me
a lot of them are just like jocks who
love sports and stuff
and they're just i'm just like never get
never get a dab don't forget again never
get a job man
[ __ ] god this is crazy though that all
the kids want to be youtubers now
was it like 35 of japanese kids want to
be youtubers
yeah because i was googling it for the
uk as well i got curious and there was
like youtuber wasn't on there it was all
like doctor
nurse something like [ __ ] they
didn't [ __ ] they didn't give these
kids the prompt give them the prompt
tell them they could be a youtuber i bet
they'll do it i don't know it's like
being a youtuber still
looked down upon in the uk because i
haven't been there for like a long time
i don't know is it look down upon
america like would you say it is or was
it kind of like
i think it's neat i think they they
claim it to be cool and neat
yeah i mean it's considered cool and
neat here for the younger generation
right right yeah but the older
generation are like that's not a joke
that's not a job and the problem there's
still some of that in the uk i think
yeah yeah yeah and the problem but the
problem with that notion especially in
japan is that
the old people who say that are the
majority of the people who live here
you know so it's still considered like
okay yeah i guess this is like
the new generation job kind of thing but
yeah we'll never [ __ ] understand
in japan i'd say youtubers receive cred
when they go on national television
which it happens a lot in japan like
i've noticed yeah yeah the moment like
for example the prime example
started going on the variety shows
that's when everybody's like
wow that's amazing and he edits all his
own videos he works like 82 hours a week
and i'm like [ __ ] that's
all i've got yeah i think i think from
this from the surface level it's easy
thing what a [ __ ] bunch of weirdos
but like when you actually see all the
work and you can like
actually see that they're like talented
at what they do i mean not me but
you can you know you can really
appreciate what's going on it's
hilarious though to see like all these
like traditionalist like japanese tv
presenters being like wait
so you're your own editor and your own
producer
and your own host cameraman and your own
cameraman
[Music]
no we don't believe that [ __ ] can just
go a quick tangent real quick about
japanese tv because i was watching the
other day
so you know you know the whole meme
where they hehe they react to everything
yeah i don't realize they react to
everything yeah yeah yeah so so
it was really like some i think someone
had died some famous person
and i didn't realize they had a reaction
camp for the [ __ ] funeral
and i'm like and i'm sitting there and
i'm thinking like this is
how uncomfortable would you be as the
host or they're like react react to this
guy's death this guy's crying at the
funeral react
and this is what's good like i was like
dude i was like am i missing like i
don't want to be rude to you know
maybe i'm missing set but i'm pretty
sure there's nothing like you know
the japanese culture that is like you
should be reacting oh no no no no no
that's just weird i've been on japanese
tv multiple times it is corrupt as [ __ ]
and like
i get that i get where the reaction cam
is there but i think i i was just
thinking i'm like maybe you should like
just
turn it off
[Music]
it's a little loud isn't it sorry i'm
going to change it no no so much of
japanese television is really
hypocritical to like the japanese
culture itself because like
we pose ourselves to be so modest right
and and like private and all that stuff
but then it's like oh this person's
crying zoom in on their face
but then it's like when you're shooting
uh
shazam like when you're shooting like a
interview or something outside
everything is mosaic in the background
so you can't like know anything and
without their consent or whatever it's
like there's such a hypocrisy there
yeah the whole like privacy law thing is
just [ __ ]
ridiculous like i remember oh my god i
[ __ ] remember there was one prime
example of like
it was like kind of like a paddle like
this right like a host yeah panel kind
of thing
and i guess like one of them had like a
water bottle but the entire water bottle
was blurred
like like but there was no like but
there was no logo on it
it was like the shape of the water
bottle would insist that it's like a
specific brand of water that's not
sponsoring
so their option blur out the entire
[ __ ] bottle and i'm like
that's as long as i can't figure out
with japanese tv what's go
why they're blowing some things and why
they're not because sometimes they'll
show you shots where nothing's blurred
and then the next shot
it'll be blurred yeah everything's
blurred and it like flips between
you know and i can't figure it out
because it's not like in one shot
there's branding stuff like there's
branding there's people like
and then it just completely cuts the
complete opposite and i can't figure out
why it does it and it drives me [ __ ]
insane there
there's somebody's just slacking yeah i
don't know yeah yeah they're like dude
i'm not going to sit down and mosaic
three more scenes of this [ __ ] oh my god
you know and then adding in all of the
[ __ ] like subtitles and [ __ ] as well
like
i feel dude i feel bad for japanese like
tv editors
actually i did something with pokemon
last year
before the pandemic really went wild and
they had me mosaic frame by frame
every single person at a lala board
every single man woman child everyone
even the staffers they had me mosaic why
not just mosaic the entire screen of
that
i know and just like just cut out the
pikachu line that's like walking down
like so like pikachu will kind of do
this like i should have just done that
same thing at the end of the day but
yeah it was it was so messed up and it
took
hours and i'm making it sound like i did
it my husband did it
i think we need more vlogs where people
are wearing like the cones for dogs
where you can just only see in the cone
hey guys i'm at uh disneyland today
just inside the cone honestly and it's
like i don't know why
they do that for some scenes and they
don't do their fathers because like
there is never a moment on japanese tv
where like everything is blurred out
that looks good yeah it just looks like
[ __ ] it's like what am i looking at
yeah where is this what the [ __ ] a lot
of youtube videos look better than
japanese tv oh yeah
i mean then a lot of their shows just
send a guy with a camera to this place
and do the thing
yeah exactly i mean they can get away
with more things right because like i
guess if it's a big japanese company
they really
really worry about that [ __ ] as we find
out quite a lot
yeah i mean there's a lot of bureaucracy
here um
but yeah i mean i don't watch too much
japanese tv i'd rather watch youtube
i don't watch japanese tv it's a great
inspiration they have like really
bizarre ideas
like there's so many cool tv shows that
they have i don't know which ones i've
spoken in the park like
i swear to god i don't know what i've
spoke about on the podcast i talked
about quite a few in the last one that
were
didn't we did i did i mentioned about
the tv one where they basically just
like
go to random people and they're like hey
uh
we'll pay for your dinner if you take us
to your house yeah yeah yeah yeah that
was really cool
what they would like go outside onsens
wait for the old guys to like finish
at the bath house at like midnight and
they would be like hey take us to your
house
what would they show at the house just
like their stuff how they live
how they live like what they do like
their story it's kind of interesting
really because normally i guess everyone
normally has
most people have some kind of
interesting story about it yeah yeah
yeah why they ended up and especially i
think is when that when you're older
you've lived through a lot of things
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah honestly back when i used
to watch a lot of japanese tv i got like
a lot of inspirations for
my youtube channel like literally like
the reason why i do so many like quiz
based videos i was just gonna say
that those are my favorites purely like
all of those ideas i'll fully admit were
taken
straight off japanese tv i was just
watching um
last night there was like a three hour q
summer special where it's like a quiz
god or quiz king or whatever and it's so
fun because they have all these
um all these like tokyo university
graduates or like
postdoc like candidates or whatever and
they're so brilliant like they're all
like mensa geniuses
and they know so much about everything
and like even though they can't like
let's say speak
english they know more vocabulary than
me which is like really gross
they're like oh yeah i can't speak it
but i but i know everything yeah i can
say
mitochondria like and i can spell my i
know
you knew that in english like it's one
thing but then again it is kind of like
japanese english but still
yeah uh it's really impressive and it's
fun and um
the quiz like quiz shows are
really well done to this day i still i
think that's like one type of japanese
tv i still watched to this day at the
quiz shows
they seem like they're willing to try
out ideas more than i think western tv
is i feel like we're
very refined in our ideas we like to
like
stick with what works and just only like
reiterate on top of it in some way
small iterations at a time and then
there's like weird shows in the uk
actually so
i mean there's witcher but it seems like
with japanese tv it's everything's weird
everything's a weird show which is why i
guess they
you know a lot of this got exported to
foreign
tv channels that's how japan got his
image in the first place right yeah i
guess like did you ever watch like the
american ports of like japanese tv shows
oh
in america no i got uh i was able to
watch
fuji tv when i was growing up in japan
so
it was just in japanese so i never
really thought anything so you never
watched like the
the the spin-off of like silent library
with like all the wwe players
wait what else are you okay
so silent i guess i thought everyone
knew this one so silent library is based
off uh like a japanese
tv show it was actually just one segment
of a really famous japanese tv show
called
sky it's like really like really famous
like going off like 30s or something
and there was one segment called silent
library where it was five comedians
inside of like
like a proper like public library and
they would pull out of a hat
to do like a bunch of like punishment
games that are like either really
painful or like really loud or like you
know get like a reaction at them but
because they're in a public library
they have to be really quiet while doing
all of it so i remember there was one
where there was like
one of the comedians like gets like
[ __ ] slapped in the face by like
a sumo wrestler and he can't make a
sound like he can't make us
like a reaction sound and obviously the
other comedians can't laugh
sumo in the let's see the library to
slap someone just come in the library
slap this dude
but then i guess like american tv i
forgot which station it was but american
tv took that
and replaced the comedians with the
wrestlers
from the wwe so they were like
it was actually really funny because
these wrestlers would be in a public
library
[ __ ] doing like german suplexes to
one another like
it's a [ __ ] full on but like all
really silently
and it was still a library like this
yeah it was like a proper library yeah
yeah but still it was like just seeing
like all these
[ __ ] massive six foot brick [ __ ]
houses doing german suplexes to one
another
quietly as possible unfortunately most
british tv shows don't get good
adaptations in the us not really
no because british humor is weird yeah i
feel like the only good adaptation i've
seen
is the office yeah i i would like hazard
to call that an adaptation because it's
nothing like the british office
they like it was one of the few examples
where they took what
worked about the office and did their
own version it's completely different
but it works
in a different way yeah they still paid
homage to it right like yeah
the first season is very similar to the
actual office yeah first season's very
hard to watch yeah exactly
that's what we like that's what we like
i totally get it i
absolutely understand but oh my god i
just skip right past it every single
time
i'm like i can't i'm so itchy when i
watch it like
i love cringy i love don't get me
started about the american version of
the in-betweeners that is
probably like a lot of people like to
forget that it exists but it's something
that exists i
i didn't even know it existed to be
honest you know the in-between no i
don't
really popular tv show that came out i
think when we were bringing garmin
university i was in like no i was i was
actually in secondary school then
it started oh it finished right i was
the same age as the characters in the
in-betweeners
as it was airing which is why it was
[ __ ] massive yeah it was huge in the
uk
especially just four students um just
being like pretty
accurate students and just messing up
life situations
yeah and uh you know trying to like get
girls and stuff and being [ __ ] awful
i think
it's just really cringe humor the
closest way i can describe it is like
it's american pie
kind of but like everything goes wrong
yeah everything's scripted though
yeah yeah it's like a drama it's a
scripted like it's a sitcom so it's kind
of like an american pie sitcom but just
with british humor where you see these
like four no yeah four misfits just try
to get laid
and it no matter what they do it always
goes wrong
right right and they just cause awful
situations like everything
it sounds amazing the british version is
[ __ ] horrible
yeah i never knew about the american
version and to be honest
it's so bad it's so bad
this episode of trash taste is supported
by manscapes gentlemen
you know what i care about what these
nuts we're
we're grown men we're growing them
manscaped is the best in men below the
waste grooming and hygiene manscape is
taking over the world and is now
available in all of europe canada
australia new zealand
manscape is trusted by over 2 million
men worldwide join the movement for all
your below the waste grooming needs
that's right europe and australia are
about to get a lot less
hairy if you live in the eu you can now
purchase manscaped products
if you live there you've gone years
without using the right tools for the
job
now's the time for a change look i'm
sure all men can agree with this but
shaving down there it's a bit of a pain
in the butt it's just a little bit
annoying people always you know be like
ah
door whenever and then never end up
doing it but now manscaped has this
assortment
of handy tools that's why manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer
the manscaped engineering team spent 18
months
perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created that was a sentence
i just read
and they just released the new and
improved lawnmower 3.0
goddamn look at this thing sexy the
third generation trimmer features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to the
advanced skin safe technology
pioneered by manscape when i tell you
this is premium i mean premium the
battery will last up to 90 minutes
so you can take a longer shave joey damn
and don't forget the waterproof
technology allows you to groom in the
shower one of the coolest features
is that it has an led light which
illuminates grooming areas
for a closer and more precise trimming
experience there it is right there
they've also upgraded to a 7000
rpm with quick stroke trademark
technology
and let's all forget about the charging
stand show your mower off loud and proud
because this intelligently designed
stand is a convenient charging dock
powered by usb
so for you viewers of trash days out
there you can get 20 off and free
shipping using our code trash test at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at
manscape.com and use trash taste your
balls
well thank you back to the episode back
to the episodes
no back to the episode no back to the
episode
back to the episode then are you having
any other like american shows that i've
tried to adapt british shows that are
just i'm just blind oh what's the
taskmaster had one have you seen test
mascara what is task mask
really popular comedy show in the uk
they tried they adapted america it's not
very good wait task master
yeah isn't that a super hero villain
it sounds like it sounds like a c tier
like dc
it's a really really popular comedy like
show in the uk where like comedians are
told to do like a task
and then yeah they're judged on how they
did it like a really specialized
maybe i mean this oh god this is
otherwise like it's just
training it's just apprenticeship you
should watch it
watch it watch it internship in turn in
turn the challenge and turn the
challenge
so i guess like growing up uh in japan
or not so much well you're spending a
lot of your childhood
in japan right is there like i don't
know
i feel because like as someone who also
spent a lot of his childhood in japan
there's like certain types of i guess
like anime or
shows or like manga where it's like it's
only really like read or watched by
people who were in that kind of
situation you know i mean like a lot of
like
the slice of life [ __ ] like someone who
did this yeah like
i said like stuff like that right yeah
you grew up with all that kind of
absolutely they were my favorites
was so big and huge um that was like my
major
thing whenever i'd come to japan i would
record those shows and i'd bring it back
i was exactly right and i'd watch it
like throughout the year
yeah it sounds so bizarre to me like the
thought of just like
going away to a foreign country it's
rich right yeah
everybody thought like i was like hella
rich because every summer it's like oh
i'm vacationing in japan i'm summering
in japan
but it's not it was kanji test and then
smash cuts
it must be like is it is it weird like
going to a foreign country just having a
com
like i mean even then back then japan
was even more isolated at that point
right it must be so bizarre
just having to go back and forth between
those two like no one in my school
went anywhere foreign and like studied
there but that's that's because
were there any asian people in your
school one asian person came to my
school as i was leaving
i'm not i wish i was joking i literally
went to i i grew up in like the
whitest part of like the whole country
and like there was like
never any uh like foreign people i was
only like one of two
asian kids in my whole like school
career yeah
i was the only one i was i was getting
one as well and like i grew up in
brighton
which is now seen as like the very
progressive city that's like the gay
capital of
it wasn't yeah it was the gay capital i
don't know if it still is but it was
like now it's seen as the very
progressive city in england
um but it wasn't like that when i was
growing up i'll tell you that because
like yeah i was
literally the only asian person in my
school my school wasn't small we had
like
in in sixth form we had like 800 people
yeah yeah
my graduating class had like 600
something people and
by by high school there were a few more
but like middle school elementary school
like
or i'm sorry secondary school or i get
confused about it i
get confused as well yeah we say
secondary school we say we say secondary
school but i
like i just call it high school now
it wasn't really weird for me i knew i
was i got to
step into a different world every summer
and also like i love
my family and because my mom was able to
bring me back
every year it kind of stayed we bring
you back like
sorry didn't get the plane tickets
yeah like i don't know i felt very
connected so
it wasn't that stark of a thing like it
was just a thing for me right like oh
every summer i go to japan
like every winter i go to japan and
maybe it's because i also went two times
a year that's also why
i didn't feel like i only got to go once
you are lucky though we weren't in the
same world class i'd have been like
rayna rainey [ __ ] tell me everything
how did they go what
are you doing you'd be into japan dude i
was yeah as a kid yeah i was yeah
always i mean i guess that's why i'm
here right now right now
ever since a kid i always just thought
that like asia was super cool and that
like because
to europe it's like the furthest place
right which is funny right because
people in asia are like oh man europe is
so close
yeah yeah yeah i mean that now i really
like europe when i was going i'm like
mom i don't want to go to [ __ ]
romania i don't want to go to bulgaria
or whatever like i came to like asia i
want to go see
because it all [ __ ] looks the same in
europe but it doesn't but
as a kid it all feels the same of course
i remember
when i was like maybe 12 or something
we were shown big bird goes to japan
in one of our history classes oh no and
one two three
is ichini was really huge and then
everybody came to me all of a sudden and
they're like
do you have a kimono
do you pay in yearn like they didn't
know what the [ __ ]
like that was i think the first like
super fascination that people had and i
was like really
a big bird literal big bird
made you interested in japan and they're
like really ohio which is a state in the
u.s
ohio means good morning [ __ ]
yeah we speak a different [ __ ]
language than you
bro like yeah so that was my experience
growing up
so there wasn't like there wasn't like
kids who were like into the culture that
were like brain
i got to ask you things you know i had
um a
parent that was very into japan um
yeah and like she'd really want her
daughter to be friends with
japan and she like always wanted to have
tea with my mom
um green tea and of course
that's all we drink yeah she was like
matcha um
but yeah that was that was like the only
um
hyper concentrated interest i think
anybody had i did not
care for this girl like man yeah it
sucks i always wanted to learn more
about it but you're just so limited what
you could find because i didn't know
anyone
on the internet i didn't know anyone who
knew anyone yeah even through the
internet as well it all came from like
second third-hand accounts yeah
like documenting it right you can't get
to like really know
yeah but yeah so just like read forums
and have like
piece things together i think this is
yeah like i i i think this is like
the right thing i'm not really sure but
like i'll ask i look around because you
know i always just loved games as well
and games was like a huge thing
i was like where these games come from
um yeah so gaming
was the other thing i think that brought
attention to my nationality that was
really like when ddr came everyone's
like
wow japan like can you are you can you
sing
butterfly or like candy like that was
that was it that was a big
it's
sushi every day oh my god
yeah oh yeah i guess actually uh food
was a little bit of a deal
ramen wasn't that big back then but like
it's big now right yeah
huge i mean japanese cuisine i feel like
exploded during my lifetime it wasn't
that big when i was growing
up but now it's like in the uk do you
think so i feel like we still only
really have like sushi in the uk
yeah there's the occasional ramen place
but nothing like
worth getting super excited the us has
completely
taken that was everywhere yeah but there
wasn't a single ramen restaurant in
america where i'm like
this is good yeah me neither i mean it
would be hard right
all of them well to be fair i in vegas i
did go to a place of ramen place which
dead ass was called naruto
that gets points just for that and i was
like
why are we not eating there every day
it's [ __ ] amazing i became so picky
with ramen here
it's so it's so easy to [ __ ] up i didn't
realize yeah it's like
when you're not here and you're not
eating the ramen here you're like oh
yeah what's wrong with
it same thing but then when you come
here and you're like broth is four
percent too salty yeah yeah
the noodles were slightly undercooked
this is really embarrassing for you this
is your job
just become like an absolute [ __ ]
food snob when you live here longer yeah
it's like i never used to give a [ __ ]
about like the type of ramen or the type
of sushi but yeah
yeah but now i'm like no no i only eat
one specific
sushi train franchise is it anywhere
else 100 yen sushi get the [ __ ] out of
here
so many of them [ __ ] up the pork like if
it's so like old and like tough and i'm
like what did you do to this party
like the perfect yeah it has to be like
the perfect texture that just like kind
of falls apart in your mouth
yeah like i i find myself eating ramen a
lot less in japan than thought i would
yeah like sushi [ __ ] slapstick also i
could eat that any day also ramen
[ __ ] takes you out of business for
the day like you can't
you can't do anything so heavy and it's
so bad for you like it's delicious but
like
it's extremely bad for you it's really
bad for you and like you you're not
supposed to drink the whole broth like
that's the killer
i knew i looked at you for a reason like
i knew you were like white guy of course
because when i go anywhere i'm like i
don't want to feel like i'm leaving
anything
all right i feel rude so i'm like i look
at the guy making i'm alright [ __ ] okay
i guess i'm gonna just drink the [ __ ]
dead seed okay to be fat yeah okay yes
that okay the sodium is through the roof
sometimes some of the bowls have like
the thank you message at the bottom if
you drink it
is that what that's like that's how they
literally because i want to see the
thank you message
most of the time there isn't and do you
get sad when you yeah actually i get
super i get real [ __ ] sad
i drink like a liter of this thing i
feel awful all day i
have to like lie down and then i didn't
even get a thank you thank you
i'd like to think that the guy is like
nice guy he made my life a little easier
he cleaned it but he
didn't give a [ __ ] he probably just gets
the pressure washer
and then it's like clean there we go oh
god yeah ramen you definitely get picky
in japan but
that's also because you know there's so
much there's a lot of factors to it
right like is the ramen too
is the noodle too chewy like is the
broth too fatty but it's also like
personal
also sometimes also sometimes you get
like rushed and when it's super busy
you're like
oh yeah like if like all the famous
ramen places in tokyo always have lines
and you're like expect to eat it get the
[ __ ] out yeah you can't go with friends
because it's not really what it's for no
there's not going to be like three seats
empty well i know you guys have like
constantly told me how [ __ ] fast i
eat my ramen yeah
and it's like skilled it's literally
just been i've been conditioned to eat
it
joey [ __ ] vacuums is ramen because
i'm normally the one who's super fast
yeah and then it's really weird being
with joey where he just destroys the
ramen like
hold up because like i've been to when i
was still visiting here
and my like uncle would take me to like
the best [ __ ] like ramen
place he's like we're leaving we're
leaving right now
it's always like this this store can
only hold like three people sitting down
yeah so it's like you can't
and there's always like 20 people
waiting outside so it's like if you're
if you're dilly dally in here
you're not going to be welcomed back
because you can't you can't talk with
your friends and you go in there no no
it's like you've got to eat concentrate
yeah yeah and actually it is a skilledy
robin really
really fast too it like scares people
but you know that slurping
that you're supposed to do that's uh
that's like a purposeful
so you can just eat the whole thing
while it's piping hot yeah which is like
a really
straight like you're not you're not
weirdly not there to enjoy
it yeah it's there for a purpose for a
purpose
yeah like fill my stomach and get the
[ __ ] out yeah but there's some places
the ramen is so good that you're like i
need to take my time like i can't
you know i know i know which is like
which is why i'll try and go at like
awkward times like three people yeah
yeah three because then you can normally
there's never a line it's like it's it's
you know
dinner's no one's coming for dinner no
one's going for lunch right yeah good
but that but then you then you [ __ ] up
your eating spot like schedule for them
right
i always feel so ungraceful getting out
of the stools i'm like now
i'm i look like i'm two months pregnant
and i gotta like
wedge my way
if you're getting on the train
afterwards the moment you sit down the
train it's like sleep is activated
it does rock you to sleep it really does
food cold
but it's so good go eat it just don't go
to ichiran right no i like it shirana
she what's good
it's i remember when you took me there
for the first time because i've never
been to ichiran because i've already
been to like local places so this is
i think it was the day after our medical
exam
yeah and connor's like guys we've got to
go to ichiran well i wanted to i wanted
to get [ __ ] up by ramen because we
we we were not because we were so we
weren't allowed to eat
before like the we weren't allowed to
eat from like 8 p.m the night before
which doesn't sound bad when you're told
you can't eat bites oh yeah yeah
then you're like no i'm hungry yeah yeah
and i remember we were eating it and
connor's like come on how is it how is
it and i like i've never had
such a hard time forming an opinion
until that moment that's what i'm saying
ichiran is the most solid five out of
ten yeah but
the thing i like about it is a chain of
ramen that's seen as like very touristy
i guess yeah yeah the one thing i do
like about it though is that you can
i know and i know this is in isn't a
thing for ramen you're not supposed to
do this you can customize the spice
level
yeah which yeah i really like spicy
ramen and nowhere ever does spicy ramen
so it's nice that you can do it you can
be like hey put a habanero in this [ __ ]
and then they do it and then you can
order like extra meat extra noodles
like it's all chill yeah that's what
but it's like the most comfortable i
like it i i know
that i won't like get a two if i go
there right like a solid five like i
know i
it was just like a solid five and i'm
just like well that was
a meal that i consumed and
it wasn't bad and it did the job i am
now
full thank you if you very much
ign review for ichiran it'd just be like
good five out of ten
there's like nothing else you can say
about it wouldn't you give us your ass
pretty good
check it out you should go there first
as a baseline no i agree
that's a really and they're all over
shinjuku there's like a three right next
to the station
so oh are there yeah all in the sketchy
parts
yeah because we left when we left that
itchy round we literally walked out and
a guy come up he's like you want sex
you want sex and we're like literally in
front of the station i'm like what is
happening
it wasn't like even late at night it was
like it was like midday it was midday it
was literally lunch time
like do you want lunch do you want lunch
because it's english
yeah it's because yeah it's cause you're
it's cause you're
but uh bug foreign people yeah because i
remember i asked this to um
one of the bar owners around the area i
was like why did they only like come up
to like foreigners they're like oh cause
japanese people will call the police
oh really really yeah if they're like
because because the the dudes will come
up to you
yeah they'll put their arms around you
like hey where you want to go you're
looking for some good time and it's like
leave me the [ __ ] alone yeah yeah oh
yeah i can see the japanese calling in
the police for that yeah exactly yeah if
a guy puts his arm right so they're not
going to do it and they know the
japanese aren't going to talk to them
because they're terrified i mean they
are because they just come to you and
start like they're quite intimidating
they're like
pretty pretty like up front and like
yeah you look different from everyone
else yeah yeah
yeah what are you doing yeah it's fine
though it is what it is
you deal with it yeah so like going back
to your experiences in school and
everything or being japanese
was like did were you ever like open
about watching anime or did you ever get
bullied for that
um in american school i don't think i
ever really brought it up it's not like
i was trying to keep it a secret yeah
it's not like it doesn't come up in
conversation right right and i wasn't
like these are my
interests but um oh god i do remember
something weird didn't happen
um i had to do a book report and an
autobiography and i did it on sir arthur
conan doyle
because i actually really do like
sherlock holmes but
i already know where this is going but i
also like sherlock holmes because
my favorite anime of all time is
detective kona
it's i grew up with it it's like my baby
okay
now like it's crazy but um i was
obsessed with it and all through my life
i loved it and i loved it so i started
reading like real sherlock holmes
right right and i was like i'm gonna do
my whole book report on this and i got
like
really into it like it was like a 15
minute
presentation to like ran a police stall
yeah like
she was like you already got the a like
shut the [ __ ] up
like [ __ ] we get it you're like an asian
nerd like god damn sit down
um but that was when in
the whole presentation towards the end i
started talking about detective conan
i had to explain something like about
his name right and other iterations of
his name and i was like
and in japan the most popular anime is
called detective conan
and it's about you know conan doyle but
it's not because
and i had like went on like a really
nerdy tangent you literally did like an
anime analysis video of
why conan is called everglades yeah i
did i did i did
it yeah because because um yamagocho
uses
different like specifically different
famous
literature like figures that are like
detective novelists
in his book jackets and they work their
their way into the anime
and i was like so excited about it and i
was like and then like cordelia gray
is high but i because gray is is high
like
it's a it's a tough thing to learn as a
kid but you're like man people don't
care about the things that i care about
yeah i mean like i was fired i didn't
get like bullied or anything but that
was what i was like i gotta
turn it down i am weeding people
out i gotta shut up right now i got
rinsed for saying i like one piece when
i was like 12.
why why anyone wait but you've never
even seen it no i did when i was a kid
oh really yeah
yeah they were just like why are you
watching cartoons connor we're 11. go
on literally yeah why aren't you my
parents would lie at the time they're
like what are you going to stop watching
cartoons
i'm like 13 i'm like am i supposed to
start what this is awesome though
yeah my parents kept telling me you'll
grow out this you go out of this here i
am like
about to hit you about to go to
university being like am i going to grow
up
i'm still really enjoying this right now
a career was there anything like that
in like american schools or was like
they expect you to like stop talking
about like
stuff like that like you know there
definitely was and i think it was also
like
i grew up in like you know late 90s 2000
yeah there was definitely kind of like a
we want to pretend to be older than we
actually
are kind of phenomenon however we also
i have to credit like cartoon network
for this it's a american uh television
station that had this thing called
toonami
it's not like just america yeah um that
was phenomenal and adult swim was
amazing because they would actually
show like cowboy bebop yeah yeah yeah
and
um what was another well they had like a
bunch of weird things like
blue sub six was like outlaw star was
amazing
yeah that was a good one um and then
they did like really
like random things like candidate for
goddess and
stuff like that so they would have
really like triple a
shows and then they'd like interlace
like the cbd
titles that probably were less expensive
right just to like fill that time slot
but
it was it was such a good way to
introduce i think like
this adult theme that is a juxtaposition
to what cartoons are
in the west and i feel like i also then
started like cultivating my like nerd
friends and
uh we all would like watch together and
we'd all we were all gamers so
that kind of like interwoven itself into
like it just weaved itself in perfectly
and i never was like bullied or anything
i'm so jealous because i wish i had
nerd friends just didn't exist
yeah i was growing up in like two
thousands i got sort of [ __ ] for being
nerdy i got you playing video games
yeah really yeah yeah yeah you know
you know maybe i think i just grew up in
like a really cute well i think
i was i think i've said this before in
the podcast i've always been envious of
the fact that like america seemed to be
way more open to like nerd culture
and that kind of stuff i think that the
uk is very much
not yeah because it is now it is now but
i feel it definitely depends though on
like the type of friends you had as well
because like you know they're just
lucky yeah yeah because like now that
you're so like deeply ingrained into
nerd culture with a career
was that ever like a switch where you
noticed oh being a nerd's actually cool
now
absolutely but i think
okay so i'm like pretty like headstrong
and pretty loud and obnoxious than i
always was
right i was also like obsessed with
x-files like in like a
dangerous manner right what about
like it's just so nerdy and it's like
kind of older and nerdy and like nobody
gives a [ __ ] and i'd literally
like go around singing like weird songs
i made up about mulder and scully and
how they should be together
and stuff and like i would um these are
the same people who like this eventually
turned into supernatural fans
oh my god yes but um
[Applause]
definitely and like i don't know like i
think i just didn't really
care and nobody really made fun of me
for it
because yeah i don't know i guess
there's like no reason to it's like oh
like look at that little
asian girl being obsessed with this like
weird alien show
or whatever and um i was in ap
studio art and i would like i would
literally draw
scully and boulder and once i drew them
[ __ ] and yeah
i just like i i did it i was like x
false doujin
yeah i like rule 34 like mulder and
scully
and i tried to submit it for one of my
like studio profiles
and they it got rejected so fast and so
hard and so
yeah well i know right it was so
beautiful
yeah romantic embraceable it was
romantic it wasn't like
hot and raunchy it was romantic and
beautiful and then
they weren't [ __ ] they were making
love thank you very much
it deserves to be on a roof of a church
truly
it's it's very it was very acceptable
like
i don't know if it was tasteful you
could see like some nipple but like
but um i i didn't understand why
they would like reject it so quickly so
i would modify and i'd like turn it into
mixed media
and i'd put like oil paintings on it and
then i'd like put some acrylic on it so
it would like cover you already
committed to this
this drawing huh it's like be submitted
so
you know i'd like try to fix it but it
was still rejected because they knew
what the original one was
but anyway my whole point was like i
really wore it on my sleeve without
really giving a [ __ ] so there was no
making fun of me like what are you gonna
make fun of me for liking this show
like [ __ ] like so
i don't know i feel a lot of kids though
like especially back then we're not as
strong as
you were yeah right it was a very
empowering moment i realized wait i can
just like
not care and then people won't it's like
whoa you can do that yeah
well and then people will like not make
fun of me because they realize i don't
care i'm sure they made fun of me in
secret
like doesn't matter right like yeah yeah
for sure just don't care it's uh such a
cheap code to life right
yeah seriously truly yeah i do want to
know you know considering uh
all the stuff you have done also the
the uh what's the mochi gang show was
awesome by the way yeah thank you so
much
i was like damn nice ready you killed it
that was a lot of fun it was a little
scary because in that i had to interpret
on the spot as well because
a lot of the japanese chefs that we
interviewed in manhattan
were just japanese they didn't speak
like a lick of english
really yeah and they purposefully found
them it was so good like the
researchers and first we feast are so
freaking good like jackson's amazing
he was our director but he like really
went hard and we went to like this
specialized uh kabayaki unagi shop it
was like it's the only one in all of new
york
yeah um on that like cheating like that
like seven
cool like fire thingy and he's like the
only one in all of manhattan that does
it and he
literally gets the unagi imported from
john f kennedy airport and he has to get
specialized fda passes for it because
they're live animals
oh so like yes like they went deep and
um
it was hard because again like food
lingo is technical lingo so i was like
what
did you just say like i don't know what
knife you're talking about
and they're like oh no that's like not
like it was kind of hard
but yeah but um i did feel really
special because they're like
only you would be able to do it
literally
it was so good and then you know they
they even knew
i used to be an apprentice pastry chef
like they went that deep into
researching about rules
wow yeah and they're like so since you
have like culinary experience i'm like
why do you know that
i told you that i was like definitely
still using my real name back then so
like how the [ __ ] did you find that [ __ ]
like what else do you know about i
scrubbed
and they they even knew what um culinary
school
i like got certificates that's [ __ ]
that's really creepy yeah they knew like
where i
learned uh like chocolate tempering and
they also learned where i learned like
they knew where i learned spongebob even
though that word means what is chocolate
uh it's when you raise the temperature
of chocolate to melt it and then cool it
down and then melt it again
that's what you do with metal to heat
treat it
yes so that um the white streaks don't
happen when it uh
he treats chocolate yeah it's it shocks
the chocolate but
that must have come from like
engineering techniques right yeah yeah
definitely
yeah and the real way to do it is like
use a marble slab to cool it down and
then you scrape it again and warm it up
again so that it like
really it changes the molecule you put
in more engineering than i do
man this is why i read
we see you drew a picture of mulder and
scully [ __ ]
what was that and they're making
love it's just so we found a we found a
manuscript of your detective conan
speech and uh
it's kind of cringe bro what are you
thinking about
solo research uh i was gonna ask what's
what's next then what do you what do you
what's uh
what do you want to do next like because
you've done you've done everything i
swear right yeah i really don't know i
you know i we had gochi gang season two
and
all the guests completely mapped out and
then we had to drop it and
we postponed it postponed it and then
now it's like completely in limbo
um and you know the us is like doing
pretty well with vaccinations so i think
that's what they're like really banking
on so the timeline is starting to kind
of speed up
where they can kind of see the the light
at the end of the tunnel
but man it's really hard because i just
i'm trying to make sure that that
happens beyond anything else
um it's hard to get invested in anything
right now it really is and i don't want
to have my heart broken so
it's literally just just don't get my
hopes up it's it's literally just been
that was just
tell me when it happens and then i can
get excited about it yeah but
um as we talked about before twitch is
very interesting um
but also i've been doing a lot more
voice acting because
a lot of the studios especially like
more indie gaming studios have become
more flexible with their audio specs
right so
they're they're okay with like you
sending stuff from home and
so that's looking really fun and good
during this like
like pandemic period yeah but genuinely
i don't even like really know
i'm just trying to figure it out i'm
just trying to figure it out and i think
it's almost
okay that we take the time that's like
what else are we supposed to do other
than like kind of introspect right now
yeah cause like it's like do you have a
favorite kind of like
industry or topic that you like to work
in yeah because you've worked in so many
different
like industries and stuff you know i do
like hosting
um i think that is really where i
trained the most in so to speak and i'm
the most
comfortable uh being like told what to
say but also have an impact because
you're almost like
you're in a weird position where it's
like people know you as like
a youtuber i know right but you don't
really consider yourself a youtuber
i mean it's not like a bad thing um like
i would dirty word
did you just call me a content creator
i mean in a way like i actually think
it's more impressive to be
a youtuber where i like really wanted to
be that instead of like a host that's
hired for stuff
i don't know man like i think a host
looks way more likely i mean like whoa
that's cool yeah it's like it's kind of
hard to sell i guess it's like it's my
mood
on the day yeah yeah yeah like damn
consistent employment that must be nice
right yeah but then i'm like oh but then
i guess your
your earnings are capped at some point
they are they are and your like growth
potential is definitely right
right but i do miss working with like a
technical team
i miss having like a co-host um
and i guess i miss like a professional
aspect of it although it's not like
youtube isn't professional it's just
having to take care of every aspect of
it yourself and then if it comes
crashing down it crashes down on you and
you implode
that's really frightening it is super
nice just being able to turn up and then
just do the thing and leave yeah
it's pretty good because it's like i
like i i feel like i'm really quite
technologically current right but
even even like streaming for me yeah
it's it's like confusing at times
right like just just having to set up
and having to learn especially looking
at connor's setup which just
which connor says it's easy i'm gonna be
like no it's not easy
i said it before like you could do it
too i'm like okay well okay this weighs
like i can like dumb it down and like
take away some things that you don't
need like all these
all the live sound effects yeah well i
mean you know literally like this
the stream deck alone will up the
quality of your stream which like this
tiny little thing with like
12 buttons that will just change things
or play sounds or do certain things
and it makes it so much more
professional like and makes it so much
easier yeah because
i used to have to like pull up the
software scroll to the thing i wanted to
click and then change it to like this
screen
so if i want to be like okay show all of
my face all right scroll
all the time i actually want to change
it back to the game now but now it's
like press the buttons on the side
yeah but like there's there's also times
where you know with this kind of setup
for some reason you know you you changed
one setting or something
uh you changed one setting you don't
remember you did and for some reason the
sound from your game or the sound chat
is just not coming out
somewhere and you just have to go
through this to-do list where you're
just checking
okay is this is this setting correct is
that setting correct i don't even
remember
what i did to set this up to begin with
you know it just adds a layer of
complexity yeah
i do think that there's like such a
forgiveness in streaming right like
anybody that is your fan that's watching
you oh i think
they find it charming that you have to
not like fumble around but it's very
real
right to be like oh sorry like technical
air like let me fix it and you're kind
of there for the journey
i guess that's kind of like the
bittersweet moment right because like
there have been some moments where i'm
like
there is something wrong with my stream
and i cannot
completely forgot to [ __ ] figure it
out but like it's kind of like nice to
be like just
you'd be like oh [ __ ] sorry guys you
know i'm trying to fix this thing i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is i don't
want to end the stream because we just
started yeah
and this is you know like hundreds of
people just being like it's all good bro
yeah yeah we'll wait
i don't know about that because i i i i
get that because i
you know a lot of people in the comment
section are supportive but then
you go you start going through technical
difficulties and then you see that live
view account drop and it just it never
feels good
if it's something little it's whatever
but if it's like stream like crashing
worthy like it's
very stressful yeah yeah yeah i
accidentally showed my youtube
um like all my analytics one time on on
really
like a second yeah yeah just
accidentally hit the wrong tab
yeah i actually showed the wrong thing
and i was like yeah guys all right
that's how much i made this spot though
i've done worse than that okay so
i would have i leaked the trash taste
special
that's not bad um i've leaked my ip
address
which is awful that was the most
that was just the most stressful like
realization of getting ddos
like like instant sinking feeding to be
like okay
i gotta i gotta [ __ ] sort this out
all right i literally unplugged my
internet unplugged everything i was like
google how do i how do i change my ip
address [ __ ] hell
yeah don't basically don't go on uh
don't test your speed or don't go
don't test yourself oh you stream oh
yeah don't test people
i didn't realize my my ip address was
right there
how did you save it what did you do did
you share it luckily luckily it wasn't
that complicated because i googled it
all you have to do to like change
because i don't have a static ip address
and all i had to do was like unplug
unplug yeah yeah yeah yeah plug it in
again but i i don't know at the time i
was just like
well my internet's [ __ ] yeah because i
feel like
how you handle the [ __ ] up is like the
most important part
yeah and then like when i flashed my
thing i'm like oh
you know what guys i'll just [ __ ]
show you just have a look you're gonna
look at the clip just have a look like
all right then i was like all right so i
know it seems like a lot
there's a lot of stuff just an estimate
youtube takes forty percent
you know youtube takes a car you know
there's a lot of costco involved like
it's real easy to look at that number
you know
i'm like you know tax is like 40 it's
pretty you know it's pretty brutal you
know
so basically i see none of that what i'm
trying to say is i'm broke thanks for
the ten dollar donation by the way uh
i'm kidding like that's why i tell
people i'm streaming like i i don't
stream because like i wanna like some
people do except like i wanna get more
subs
i just do it because i like playing the
game i don't like playing games alone
anymore
for me i don't know why i think that's
probably a bad thing that i've ruined
gaming alone for myself
right i only like gaming with an
audience now i don't know what this is
about me
what's wrong with me mentality that's
like literally the only thing that's
stopping me from like
fully committing to twitch is the fact
that i don't want
another one of my hobbies to turn into a
job i completely understand
yes oh that that's also my other yeah i
was falling out of love with gaming and
i think twitch really saved it for me
and that's why like when i'm streaming
i'm always like yeah dude
you know you can sub if you want but
like i really don't care if like you
know you don't need to i'm doing this
regardless
yeah yeah and uh yeah i just hope people
believe them when they say that it's so
easy to sound like [ __ ] when you say
something like that
trying to justify why you have like 30k
revenue last month you're like
oh my god um yeah you should have just
been like
i don't choose the cpm i'm like you know
it used to be like i couldn't live
and now i live comfortably you know it's
like things change you know
it's fun like sinking in my chair like
[ __ ]
i can't believe you went into justified
that's so scary i would have just like
cut the whole stream i'd be like that
was a technical error somebody hacked me
yeah damn photoshop is advanced these
days wow i left my
photoshop my own analytics damn look at
that opened up
and being like just drawn a three like
oh no just like erase one of those
yeah i think i think people know that i
think you know when you get to a certain
size people like i expect you to make
some money you know
yeah it always feels weird cause i feel
like i don't deserve it well their
estimates are also like way
yeah they are they are yeah someone's
like you probably make like five hundred
thousand dollars i'm like are you
[ __ ] stupid it's so hilarious like
looking up like [ __ ] websites being
like
the anime man's net worth yeah ten
million dollars
it's always like ten times more than
what you actually but it's all
it's because it's an estimate right the
rain the rain yeah
[ __ ] hilarious it's like the anime
man is worth anywhere between two
hundred thousand dollars to
10 million i'm like yeah i mean i'm sure
i am somewhere in there
i mean i i do get it now that i'm a
youtuber because like i
for the longest time i thought how much
i earned is how much everyone's earned
for
what i get and then i've only recently
realized man cbm
[ __ ] matters oh yeah and the like
subject the subject matter that you talk
about also [ __ ] matters like
i would say this like as as like a
person who does anime content on youtube
cpm [ __ ] sucks
i didn't realize how much other people
in the like
similar size of me was earning in other
fields until people started
exposing how much they earned yeah and
it was just like
you're so desperate for a video you're
like [ __ ] allow myself as a
millionaire
yeah but like again like because you
know i've also been thinking of like
getting
you know after what i'm going through
because i'm right i'm in a really busy
period but like
once i've like settled down and i can
actually start doing twitch streams more
regularly it's like all right
i want to try and figure out a way to
not make this another job
right you know what i mean because it's
like i've already done it with anime
where like
all literally all of last year and like
a large majority of 2019
admittedly i didn't [ __ ] watch any
anime because i was so [ __ ] burnt out
on it right after like
six plus years of talking about it yeah
and it's like and it's
and it's shitty because it's like i
still love it but like
i had so much trouble actually sitting
down and being like i'm gonna casually
watch an anime
yeah because i can't do it you're gonna
be like ranked watching hentai
right i can't play i can't play casual
hentai anymore i
only have ranked playlists oh dude it's
like it's ripping my [ __ ] libido
i do kind of feel that because it's not
ranked ten times
but like you do you like you do watch
anime and you're just like
is this is this useful to like my job
it's like
yeah i'm not getting out literally like
ranked in casual gaming yeah if you only
play ranked it's so hard to play normal
games it's like
it's like i could be making a video on
this yeah and if i don't
i feel like it's a place what about when
you go to like 7 11 right now you're
like [ __ ] i want to make a video but i
just want to get a sandwich but [ __ ] i
should vlog
oh my god i always feel that all the
time like i always end up taking
videos and photos at 7 11. even if it's
just like in the middle of the night and
i'm getting a strong
b-roll there yeah yeah i do and that's
how i always think which is like kind of
i think unhealthy i just want to live
in the moment and like drink my like
three strong zeros and just like
like pass the [ __ ] out but but i'm also
like well look at how aesthetic it is
i'll like have to like take
some b-roll and i'm like i'll definitely
use that at one point or whatever
but it's also a trap right like because
7-eleven will come out with something
new like literally every three or four
days
yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] now i don't want to
eat anymore
stop being a great company with great
new
items for me as a customer yeah because
like like the seasonal products in japan
they're just like this is just like a
youtube gold mine yeah yeah because it's
it's
just japan is a youtube channel it is it
is i mean don quixote was
made for youtube it really was it's like
do you are you running out of video
ideas go to don quixote yeah yeah just
to be inspired it's not just that but
like i think japan
as a country is just optimized for every
kind of [ __ ] content out there oh
yeah my god
i've never seen a country that is more
aesthetic than japan it's kind of not
fair
like you did you were talking about this
the other day yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
we were like walking down what like was
it nakamura
yeah and it was just like this random
street in this random area and i'm just
looking around being like
that's really [ __ ] aesthetic isn't it
my god oh my god
god out loud to me was like i hate
how aesthetic japan is like literally
everywhere i can turn any corner
and i'm just like damn that looks good
really yeah
i feel like because you know like for
example when you go to starbucks in the
uk i feel like this is ruining the
architecture like
there's such like classical buildings
that look great it's like oh that's
fantastic
but in japan they look really [ __ ]
cool and japan is so good at decorating
everything yeah
starbucks they've like they have like
100 like figured everything out yeah
yeah yeah everyone is obsessed with
starbucks right yeah and it's like
they're so good like all the sakura cups
right now like everything's sakura
yeah they change it next month it's
gonna be something else it's like
they've gamed it so well yeah
and it's just like every little
restaurant even if it's just like a
local restaurant or
like a big chain they've like
personalized their looks so much that
you know you go you can go to a
different restaurant and have like a
completely different experience and
it's just kind of ruined like i don't
know
if ruin is the right word but like it's
it's set my expectations
unreasonably high for when i go back to
england and everything kind of looks
like you've been to the uk i've never oh
i have once i went once for this like
sony
uh square enix uh sponsored thing i
think it was like a
a vr before vr was perfect just drop in
the big names just like you're like
pokemon
you know sorry i didn't read it
it was before vr was perfected so
everybody threw up everywhere
it was like a really big problem it's
like an episode from family i
was just [ __ ] vomiting
um it was not that fountainy but yeah it
was really similar
uh it made everybody sick and yeah yeah
but um
that was the only time i ever went and i
was so in love with it
everything was so lovely and beautiful
is the architecture fantastic
i thought so [ __ ] you confidence
like coming to japan i'm like japan's
way more aesthetic than the uk
i think i think i think tokyo building
is like ugly sometimes they're like
really messy
and like dirty sometimes i don't know it
depends on the district
yeah there are some parts where i'm just
like yikes this is like
kind of gross what did you like about
the uk
i'm curious um let's see our hotel was a
very like classical
hotel you're very lucky oh yeah i know i
was lucky
um and i loved the breakfast oh my god
the breakfast was phenomenal
english breakfast oh so to be fair
english breakfast was [ __ ] fun
it was good [ __ ] amazing and um
you know everybody kind of kept to
themselves yeah that's right
people do like that i like it i like
that it's it's not british people
keeping to themselves it's americans
unable to this is i this is why i i feel
like when i moved here i felt like there
were a lot of parallels between japanese
and british culture like the way though
it's like keep yourself don't make
noises
head down yeah don't worry about it
don't don't talk on public transport
don't do that
why would you do that don't do that yeah
maybe that's why i just like innately
really liked it but you know like you
said before japan
does kind of have this like romantic
weird
admiration with europe so i think i mean
culturally
i guess like personality-wise we're also
the same keep to ourselves like be quiet
but there's a lot of things i think in
japan that like wanted to be like the uk
yeah right yeah i feel like the uk were
pretty good at knowing when to
be loud and all rowdy i guess yeah at
least i feel like we are but i don't
know what was the drink i had
pims is good pims is good
honestly i i [ __ ] with people it's good
it's like a summer cocktail drink where
you just put like a bunch of fruit in a
drink and it's like a ten percent
alcoholism it's quite strong yeah
kind of like a long island iced tea
fruity no no no don't say long island i
see you okay
i'm sorry that that'll give the wrong
they'll give them all right super super
fruity and fresh tasting cocktail that's
quite strong tastes good every
everything
tastes good no it doesn't island i see
is what you take when you get [ __ ]
and if you go to a british barbecue
everyone brings pims yeah
yeah it's very normal sounds great that
was delicious i had it like every night
and then you know you'd like feel better
with the breakfast in the morning yeah
but yeah i
it was really lovely i wanted to go
again but they were like there's no
timing and whenever i had
like vacation time i'd always choose
japan
[Music]
i'm sorry i was curious what people
think about the uk because obviously
when you're british you're like [ __ ]
hate you're here i mean as well i'm
tired of being british
as a sherlock holmes
i [ __ ] myself like it was did you did
you go to baker street
no i didn't because the the the
underground station for baker street has
like
um all the walls like in the shape of
like outlines of uh the characters like
on like and tiles yeah that's really
oh really yeah yeah so a lot of those
the really historic stations
all the underground stations have like
something to have for it like i think um
where the globe theater is it's a bunch
of shakespeare stuff all over the
underground station
wow that's lovely japan kind of does
that too in a sense but a lot more like
subtle yeah i think yeah we're really
proud of our history in britain i think
yeah it probably shouldn't be at some
time
but some things are good they're like
shakespeare yeah forget the colonization
stuff
shakespeare jesus christ because like
for me at least as a brit i feel like
london is pretty cool
london's a cool city um but sorry i feel
like i always bring a brit i just love
hearing what people think about the uk
it's really interesting
yeah of course i care about what people
think about japan yeah yeah well let me
tell
you okay i mean like
london's cool london's like really
different i feel though london's like
kind of in its own bubbles
totally different you go out of london
and like to me every every kind of place
in england kind of feels the same i mean
like
i would say i do kind of miss the
countrysides of england countryside's
really [ __ ] beautiful
um but for me i just don't get any
variety in england
right and that's what i love about japan
i feel like i can get so many different
experiences here
and you know i i feel like especially in
covert times when we have been stuck in
japan even
even in those times i feel like i've
been able to be blessed with a lot of
variety in the experience i've had even
being stuck in one country and i feel
like if i was living in
any other country i would be way more
bored than i am
oh i can't imagine [ __ ] being in
lockdown in australia right now because
it's like
dude there's nothing to [ __ ] do if
you don't have a car like and you're not
even allowed to like drive around right
like i can't walk anywhere
right so it's like well [ __ ] what am i
going to do look at the [ __ ]
same cockatoo 70 days what is a cockatoo
you know what cockatoo is a bird it's a
yeah it's a giant bird yeah
that sounds badass to you i mean
they're parrots so yeah i mean trained
ones can
i watched a tick tock of like a cockatoo
sing a song by itself when the owner
goes away and it was amazing yeah
like which is like a kind of smaller
cockatoo and like we taught it to sing
the adams family theme song
that's so cute and uh imitate the
microphone um so the microwave
like the microwave beeping noises so
like it got so good to the point where
like
it would make beeping noise of the
microwave and i legitimately thought
someone was using the microwave oh my
god like
every now and then like he'd make the
microwave like like the button pressing
sounds that's right
and one of us would go into the kitchen
be like he's using the microwave
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] cool there'll be
an episode of like
joey's haunted uh microwave
[Music]
and yeah it would imitate that sound so
it's so many times during the day we
think the phone is ringing and we'd walk
in and just not ringing
we could that's that'd be so annoying it
got very annoying
if they could do like the the vibrating
noise perfectly when
someone could do that i knew someone who
could do that you could do this
perfectly yeah yeah it was kind of like
suspicious
i didn't think it was that hard yeah he
did go to the tanga factory so
i've noticed joey is like surprisingly
good at doing sound effects like
we're in karaoke the other day and joey
just does like the r2d2 sound effects
and like the x-wing sound effect and
it's just like
you know the you know in star wars the
r2d2 when you like scream
yeah i know yeah yeah i can do that like
surprisingly right now
i don't know if i know if i want to do
it now because the [ __ ] microphone
yeah and i can do like the x-wing like
you know the scream
sound what yeah i feel like all right
like you have to do it now
i don't know it's just it's just i guess
i guess it's just i have a good ear on
him yeah
yeah anyway though what's for pressure
on but uh yeah yeah yeah actually i want
to
go back to how japan is super varied
because i actually
never understood that about japan being
such a tiny island country and yet
having
even dialects be so different throughout
all of japan
how is that possible like how did that
even happen like how did we stay so
separated in all of our like
clans so to speak look at the uk right
like
the uk is similar yeah i guess so it's
like 20 different accents just in london
yeah it's like if you drive 10 minutes
it's a totally different accent
sometimes
yeah and i feel like it's certainly like
if a country's been around for a while
it happens right especially because
there was before travel was widely
you know available i guess i mean in the
case with japan like
brief history of japan like japan was
20 pieces yeah it was in like you know
50 different pieces and each of them was
technically their own country
until it was all founded in like the
1600s right so for like
over 2 3 000 years each place
was just like a different country it
just blows my mind because like even
so i'm in shizuoka right and i'm like on
the side that's
rather close to tokyo um it takes
longer to get to the opposite side of
shizuoka than it does to go to tokyo and
i went there for like some kind of job
and i couldn't understand the shopkeep
person
i didn't figure it out i was like i'm so
sorry and i have
a shizuoka accent in japanese like i
accidentally let like the dialect slip
and stuff but right
even then i was like i don't i i can't
figure you out like i
do you speak english yeah it's crazy
it's crazy like i had that same thing
like when i because my family's from
miyagi which is up north right
and like i have so many of like my
grandma and granddad's like
cousins who still live in like [ __ ]
tiny villages in the middle of like the
mountains
where it's like there are some villagers
that have their own like village
specific dialect
wow and like village specific like words
and i remember like
one of them like came out to the city to
like see my grandma for like
you know in like first time like 15
years or something wow
it just came out and she did like a lot
of like japanese dialects
have like they end their sentences in a
very like specific way
yeah the ending is specific the ending
is very specific right right so like in
you know uh what's like an example like
in in sendai normally right we end all
of our sentences in bet
yeah yeah instead of sword on there and
like you know i guess
we saw that out yeah that's not for us
right so like
usually it's sold on it or so doesn't it
right like that
this net turns into just whatever
different [ __ ] when it comes to dialects
yeah so ours has been yeah i've been
i've been winging it man when people i
just say oh i sold this and then and
then i'm like am i doing it right i
don't [ __ ] know i just hit people
saying yeah
yeah no that's fine because that's like
the standard right yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a
standard huge like there's standard
regular language
but my but my grandma's like cousin dead
ass she ended all of her sentences with
yeah and i'm just like
and i was just like the weave inside of
me is frothing right
and it's so it's a real thing it's a
real thing it's a real anime character
i know it's like i thought she was like
putting it on but i'm like
why would this like 90 something year
old like four foot tall grandma
be putting on her ending all of her
sentences ending in here
like we found the promised land
go to that village super tiny village in
the middle of nowhere in miyagi and you
will find a village where everyone
ends their sentences so these people who
are posting online
were secretly from japan the whole time
the whole time
oh my god my eyes are truly open
oh that's you know older people in j i
don't know if it's all of japan but like
in my
area not eat becomes
yeah for us so yeah like um
right but like not like that though
right it literally is like dacha type of
ending yeah it's like so so darn it will
be sold on ya
like it's it's like dead ass like i wish
i was making that up
but it's so [ __ ] weird i'm like that
is [ __ ] adorable but you're also like
93.
oh my god i'm curious like do you ever
hear a british accent or like an english
dialect that you have trouble
understanding
there will be one i guarantee other
you'll be like what the [ __ ] are they
saying i mean honestly i haven't
i'm sure there are i just haven't come
across anything cockney for me
is like that's pretty tame yeah really
but the more north you go the more like
what the [ __ ]
did you say yeah like like experience
especially in england the more north i
go the more like you start you start you
start squinting with your ears just be
like
because they what they do is they start
replacing common words
with just their own version and
sometimes it's that person specific
but everyone around them just knows
because it's like everyone i don't know
it's really bizarre
yeah it's conceptual yeah yeah but
everyone just says the same thing and it
was just really bizarre can you mimic
one though i couldn't even like there's
so many british words that when people
tell me that i'm like i don't know that
means on its own but when using the
sentence i'm like i know what he's
talking about i feel like in the uk the
further north you go the more
the sentence just turns into like mush
yeah something like that
like there was there was a post on
twitter it was like what is this and it
was like british people were replying it
was an alleyway but there was like there
was like 10 different ways of saying an
alleyway
in like british english well it's not
official but like slang yeah and then
it was like i saw it because it was a
quote retreat it was like americans must
be losing their mind right
there was there was tons i gotta find
this tweet it was like crazy just i call
an alleyway but again then again i've
been americanized
yeah doing this job i've had to really
like kick out the
very dialect specifically i say cell
phone i say
elevate yeah like oh really yeah yeah
yeah yeah because i used to say lift
but yeah every time i mentioned
apartments what the hell is a lift oh
instead of loft
flat
what are you on about [ __ ] you saying
rainer
oh yeah yeah yeah but they're so
contextual though like you can
figure it out like sometimes sometimes
but
if you understand what they're saying in
the first part there's been so many
moments where i
thought this was just like a universal
word until
i said it to an american they were like
what's that
because like i always thought like
laurie oh yeah
it was just like everyone said it a
lorry driver yeah driver
how do you spell it l-o-o-r yeah
well you know like a pram right instead
of a stroller
yeah yeah like in america it's a
stroller right you put your baby in a
stroller no in
in australia we call it a prank i prefer
a baby car
a like pram oh it is a little bit long
okay interesting interesting yeah yeah
but it's like i thought everyone in the
world called it a pram
and you know babies wear nappies right
no no yeah we're nappies yeah well yeah
[Laughter]
end in australia we call them nappies
thanks for watching
well grab your bottle of water and uh
but uh i guess where can people find you
on youtube or whatever
you want to promote sure um you can find
me on youtube.com
reyna scully everything else is just
rana scully my twitter
instagram everything like that but yeah
maybe on twitch in the future
maybe maybe on twitch yeah i'll be sure
to look your
twitch and never say anything you're
whenever you see like a japanese text
pop-up like now you'll look twice yeah
yeah exactly make sure
but yeah guys go check out rayna thank
you being a wonderful guest
so much fun i can't even tell you how
much joy
you know it's just been good to catch up
yeah it's been far too long
yeah and i think we were saying this
during one of the breaks but like i
i talked i got to talk about so many
things i never got to reveal
and it actually feels really good trash
tastes coming at you with the
exclusivity
but also thank you very much to our
lovely patrons yeah
thank you so much who's your favorite
one rainer point to it
yeah i was gonna say that one too
one person watching this is like yes but
yeah guys if you enjoyed it uh and want
to support the show make sure to go to
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our faces
listen to us on spotify
that was that like an official thing
that we say now is that i've said it
joey says this i legit haven't noticed
that you've been saying the same thing
every time
i've been saying this for like forty
seconds have you ever shouted out like
i've read it in twitter because no joey
does it
i don't think i have i'm just like okay
just leave it at me boys okay
i gotta download too yeah but thanks for
coming around thank you so much
oh wait i forgot to give you your gift
oh sure
it's not much um so i thought it would
be cute if i brought a mount fuji
oh let's go but um it's just uh i think
like crispy chocolate things
but um and this is kind of [ __ ] up
well rsd cards are full uh so we're just
gonna say bye now
bye thank you for watching
[Music]
you